Hier ist Mobamex heute mal in etwas eingeschränkter Besetzung. Max ist nicht dabei, aber we're hiring, ne?
Steve zum Beispiel.
Thanks for coming.
I just didn't want to miss today.
Hier oder was?
Doch. Herzlich Willkommen bei BUMZACK RETURN.
Herzlich willkommen zur letzten Mobile-Max-Sendung im Atomzeit-Alter.
Ich höre mich nicht.
Du hörst dich nicht?
Oder? Hört ihr mich?
Ich höre dich. Ich höre dich ganz wunderbar. Irgendwie ist es dumpf, ja.
Das ist alles ein bisschen dumpf.
Ich höre mich auch nicht wirklich.
One, two, testing, testing.
Ja, weil ich das hier auf eurer Anfrage immer so leise mache. Ich kann das natürlich auch lauter machen. Na ja, sonst wollte er immer leiser, leiser, leiser. Jetzt wollte er lauter, lauter. Was soll ich sagen? Also, wir müssen uns überhaupt mehr bedanken. Ist euch das irgendwie bewusst? Und zwar jetzt zum Beispiel nochmal bei David, ich vergesse das nämlich immer, das ist so peinlich, der immer diese tollen Zusammenfassungen der letzten Sendung macht.
Applaus, Applaus, Applaus, Applaus.
Ja, und wir sind mal wieder zu spät. Knapp eine Stunde später, als wir ursprünglich angekündigt haben, aber wir haben eine gute Ausrede, also ich habe eine gute Ausrede, ihr seid ja sowieso raus.
Wir mussten auch keine Rauswerke reparieren.
Genau, wir mussten noch ein AKW löschen. Wir haben euch jetzt auf dem Schirm hier. Ich habe jetzt endlich was realisiert, was ich schon lange angedacht hatte. Und zwar habe ich jetzt hier einen schicken, großformatigen Kühlschrank. Leisen, aber nicht vollständig leisen, Bima. Aber leise genug, Bima. Schaut nicht so skeptisch, schaut mit ein bisschen Andacht.
Bei leise muss ich skeptisch gucken.
Na ja, ich höre auch noch mal kurz.
Ganz schön lautes Ding.
Mach mich fertig.
Na ja, solange der Chat sich nicht beschwert.
Den hört niemand. Der Bima ist so laut, man hört endlich den On the Internet.
Und vor allen Dingen ist auch formschön auf eine Raufasertapete gerichtet.
Das nennt man Textur.
Das gibt dem ganzen Struktur, wollte ich gerade sagen.
Struktur und Textur.
Tiefe.
Heute wollen wir auch sehr textur-würdig vorgehen.
Ich wollte auch gleich noch eine Bedankung loswerden. Ja. Nämlich zwei Hörer haben mir für meinen Mac Plus das Ketten geschickt. Ja. Mit OS drauf. Das eine hab ich letzte Woche erst abgeholt und mich nicht dafür bedankt. Ich hab's aber immerhin schon ausprobiert und sie gingen leider alle nicht. Also derjenige, der mir die geschickt hat, die mehreren, das Ketten, irgendwie hat die meinen Mac Plus gleich wieder ausgespuckt und heute hab ich jetzt noch von dem zweiten, der mir das Kette geschickt hat, selbige erhalten und werde das jetzt auch die Tage mal ausprobieren und schon mal alleine dafür auf jeden Fall...
Danke, danke und noch mal danke.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Das ist doch bestimmt das Kettenlaufwerk, die euch justiert, oder so eine Scheiße.
Weiß nicht, er hat die Kette angenommen und hat auch kurz gesagt so und dann hat er so Mink, Mink, Mink, Mink, Mink gemacht und meinte, nee, doch nicht, tschüss.
Du weißt, dass ich zu Hause noch so ein uralt Power-Mac hab, der ein Kettenlaufwerk hat und...
Also wenn das jetzt nicht geht mit der anderen Kette, dann komm ich auf dich nochmal zurück. Jetzt fragt hier einer im Chat, was ein Mac Plus ist.
Raus!
Meine Katze hat neulich mal einen Mac Plus vom Schrank gefegt.
Ja, das hattest du schon mal erzählt, genau, ja. Nein, Mac Plus ist halt so ein ganz alter Mac, also einer nach dem original Macintosh sozusagen, der ein bisschen mehr RAM hatte im Wesentlichen, glaub ich.
Nee, der Mac Plus war schneller, als ein 512K. Also der erste war dann der 128K, der 512K war der mit einem halben Megabyte RAM und der Mac Plus, der hatte einen Megabyte RAM, er war weiter auf vier, 800 Kilobyte des Ketten.
Ja, stimmt, genau.
Anstelle von 400 Kilobyte.
Und es ist...
Gazi.
Stimmt, hatte er auch, ja.
Tastatur mit Nummernblock.
Ich hab eine kleine Tastatur dazu.
Dann ist es nicht die originale Tastatur.
Ja, das kann sein.
Und was hat er noch so? Und ich glaube, hier diese Serienanschlüsse, die die dann mal hatten. Nee, ADB hat er noch nicht gehabt. Das war erst der Mac SE. Aber die sahen so aus wie ADB-Anschlüsse, die Serien, die er hatte.
Ja, naja, auf jeden Fall war es auch noch der letzte Mac, der hat man glaube ich zwar auch schon mal erzählt, aber es war der letzte Mac, der noch die Signaturen der Entwickler eingraviert hatte im Inneren des Gehäuses. Also wenn man den auseinandergebaut hat, dann gibt es da drin noch so Original-Unterschriften reingraviert.
Hast du die gemacht?
Das waren noch Zeiten.
Ja, ich hab schon mal reingeguckt, ja.
Ich hab jetzt mal ein Foto gemacht, ich bin nicht drauf. Aber ihr seid alle drauf.
Na Gott sei Dank, dass du nicht drauf bist.
Ja.
Ich lasse mich verleugnen.
Na auf jeden Fall hab ich diesen Mac Plus irgendwann mal auf Ebay erstanden, so aus nostalgischen Gründen. Eigentlich bin ich ja viel später erst mit dem Power-PC eingestiegen, aber...
Man muss ja auch ein bisschen nachholen, was man verpasst hat.
Ja, so eine Design-Ikone, ja. Also wirklich. Aber leider hab ich ihn noch nie Booten sehen, weil ich hab keine Festplatte und keine Bootes-Ketten.
Aber du weißt ja zumindest, wie es klingt, wenn du ihn einschalst.
Genau, angeht er. Die Röhre ist auch nur sehr leicht... Also einen leichten Shift nach links.
Na ich überlege ja, ob ich... Jetzt wo es das iPad 2 gibt, weiß ich ja nicht mehr, was ich mit meinem alten iPad machen soll.
Entschuldigung, ich hab nur getestet. Ich hab noch ein bisschen getestet. Ihr wollt ja eure tollen Heilgeräte haben. Ist ja nicht so, dass es hier nicht auch alles gibt, was man so...
Also du machst ja auch kein neues Soundboard drauf.
Wenn ich mal zu sowas kommen würde, das ist echt... Also mal ehrlich, dieser Tag war einfach wieder auf die Minute genäht. So. Und dass es dann halt dann am Ende doch eine Stunde nicht geklappt hat, weil ich noch mal verzweifelt in den Baumarkt gefahren bin. Das war zwar total sinnlos, wie sich jetzt herausgestellt hat und hätte alles gar nicht sein müssen, aber nachher ist man ja wie immer schlauer.
Aber hier Mac Plus mit iPad-Screen und so, das Problem ist ja, hat man ja auch schon irgendwie, dass das iPad ja plan ist und die Röhre gewölbt und dann passt er, also muss er ordentlich feilen, damit das da richtig drin sitzt. Aber es gibt halt schon ein, zwei Leute, die tatsächlich ihr iPad in den Macintosh, in den Classic Macintosh eingesetzt haben.
Dann könnte man, dann könnte man, könnte man Gel Break machen und dann V-Mac drauf installieren und dann mit einem Mac-Raum kann man wieder einen Mac Plus emulieren.
Oder mit diesem Terminal Emulator, diesem Classic Terminal Emulator, dann kannst du auf diesem planen iPad wieder eine gekrümmte Höhre simulieren.
Genau, die Kamera nimmt man dann, die Front-facing-Kamera, um die Spiegelung zu simulieren. Ab vor dem Spiegel-Tournieren von Alena.
So, haben wir denn noch Themen hier oder...
So läuft doch gut. Finde ich.
Denn das ist schon ungeduldig. Ja, du darfst gleich über ZFS sprechen.
Also ich habe herzlich wenig...
Du warst doch die ganze Zeit im Baumarkt.
Der Baumarkt-Dieter.
Nee, ich hab einfach auch so die letzte...
Vier Tage nur Apokalypse geguckt.
Ja, das hat dann natürlich auch echt maßlos abgehalten, diese ganze Apokalypse. Also ich finde, wenn Apokalypse, dann nicht so häufig. Ich meine, dieses Jahr ist irgendwie so an Apokalypse... Ja, es nimmt ja überhaupt kein Ende. Permanent Umstürze und Erdbeben ohne Ende, Tsunamis, jetzt auch noch AKW.
Gutenberg musst du auch schon zurücktreten.
Akkupalytzenau, wie es Herr Schneider formulierte.
Helge trifft das immer ganz gut, finde ich. Aber wir haben jetzt hier das Totale, wir machen heute eine Feedback-Sendung. Wir probieren das einfach mal aus, weil jetzt haben wir nämlich hier so schön groß, endlich mal für alle zu sehen. Links den Chat und rechts den Titter. Da könnt ihr jetzt auch mal was reintittern. Und unter anderem gibt es hier die Frage, ob der David der David ist, der früher auch Kutnar-Zusammenschnitte gemacht hat. Ich weiß es nicht. Vielleicht.
David, wo bist du?
Die Zusammenschnitte kommen immer von einem David.
Bisher kamen sie immer von einem David.
Jetzt nicht mehr, als ob er seine Identität offenbart hat.
So, aber jetzt gibt es gleich noch das Viertel. Dazu muss ich hier allerdings noch ein bisschen hin und her sinken, deswegen kann ich jetzt nicht so viel zu dem Inhalt beitragen. Aber wenn ihr unbedingt einen Q braucht, wir können natürlich einfach mal anfangen mit dem iPad 2, da wo wir letzte Woche aufgehört haben, da wir ja unmittelbar nach dieser nicht gestreamten Veranstaltung schäbigerweise und auch unverständlicherweise die iPad 2 Intro. Ja, jetzt können wir ja sozusagen, nachdem sich die Hyperventilation leicht gelegt hat, vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen mit ein bisschen Abstand und mit der für Mobile Mac so typischen Zurückhaltung, über dieses Gerät urteilen. Max, du hast ja noch gar nichts gesagt, fangen du doch mal an. Also ich meine, du warst ja letztes Mal nicht dabei, du hast noch nichts zu diesem Thema gesagt.
Das stimmt. Ja, ehrlich gesagt war es im Wesentlichen das, was ich erwartet habe. Was ich wirklich toll finde, ist dieses Smart Case. Ich glaube, das ist das Ding, was das eigentliche No-Woh an dem iPad ist. Jetzt werden wahrscheinlich sich alle kringeln vor Lachen, aber ich halte das ja für eine großartige Innovation.
Wobei ja schon einige gesagt haben, dass es dann doch am Ende gar nicht so toll ist.
Ist gar nicht so smart.
Wieso? Sie meinten irgendwie, es ist so als Cover, ist es okay, aber dass man es halt nur längs ran machen kann und dass es halt irgendwie sehr flimsy eigentlich ist. Also zum aufstellen und so eignet sich halt doch nicht so gut, wie sie jetzt in den Videos zeigen. Also natürlich für sie.
Nein, echt, die Werbung hat irgendwie übertrieben.
Das Ding ist ja noch nicht passiert.
Also dieser Marco, wie heißt er denn? Aramond, der von Insta? Arment, der meinte zumindest oder zum Beispiel, dass es irgendwie nicht so der Hit wäre. Und wenn man nicht Leder nimmt, sondern Kunststoff, dann sieht es wohl auch relativ bescheiden aus.
Muss man halt Leder nehmen.
Das sind aber 70 Euro, ist doch nichts.
Was? Ich dachte 89.
Das kann man dann direkt auf ein... Haben sie den Preis doch heimlich erhöht, neben das einfach dieses Leder-Ding da so zugepackt hat? Nee, aber ich finde, dass dieses Aufmachen, also ich hab so ein paar Videos gesehen, das scheint ja wirklich so instant zu sein, und du klappst das so auf und dann geht's sofort da.
Auf den Videos sieht es, also ich meine, ich hab's da auch nicht in der Hand gehabt von daher.
Also nicht nur auf den offiziellen Apple-Videos, sondern auch auf so unabhängigen Videos sieht es eigentlich ganz cool schnell aus. Ich frag mich, wie es so ist, wenn man das in der Hand hält, wenn man das mit links hält und mit rechts scrollt. In welche Richtung klappt man das? Das klappt man ja wahrscheinlich auch so mit, dass man es wie so ein Buch aufklappt und klappt es dann nach hinten. Und wenn man das mit links hält und mit rechts dann scrollt, flappert das denn die ganze Zeit hinten oder ist das dann halbwegs steif? Das würde mich mal interessieren.
Das sind ja angeblich, was hab ich gelesen, 21 Magnete oder was?
Hat das auch von hinten kein Magnet hält? Das wäre natürlich praktisch.
Nee, also ich hab so verstanden, dass an der Leiste jetzt erstmal... Achso, du meinst, wenn es umschlägt, dass nichts hinten so rumwackelt?
Genau, ob das dann so rumwackelt oder ob es dann von hinten... Das wäre natürlich praktisch, wenn hinten auch so Magnete dran hätten, dass es sich dann von der anderen Seite festflanscht.
Tja, soweit ich das gesehen habe, ist dem nicht so. Also hinten gibt es keine Magnete, würde ich sagen.
Aber das ist jetzt auch nur...
Wir haben alle wahrscheinlich dasselbe gesehen, diesen Teardown von I'll Fix It. Und da war meiner Erinnerung nach nur von Magneten vorne die Rede. Ich persönlich denke ja auch, dass dieses Smart Cover für mich nichts ist. Weil ich eigentlich immer das iPad so von oben in eine relativ enge Tasche reinschiebe. Und ich meine, keine Ahnung, wie gut das hält. Aber wenn das nicht fest ist, dann ist einfach die Wahrscheinlichkeit gegeben, dass irgendetwas in dieser Tasche, was sich dann von unten dagegen schiebt, dass dieses Cover einfach hochschiebt. Weil irgendwann geben natürlich auch die Magnete nach, sonst würde man es ja nicht abkriegen. Und das ist ehrlich gesagt nicht so ganz meine Vorstellung von Cover. Und dann frag ich mich halt auch, wozu man das eigentlich braucht. Außer jetzt zum Aufbocken. Aber zumindest gehen sie dieses Problem an. Also sie haben zwei Sachen damit adressiert, die ich, da erinnere ich mich jetzt deshalb noch so gut, Maxi, wir haben ja mal gemeinsam noch die alte Mobile-Max-Sendung nachgehört, die letzte, bevor das ursprüngliche iPad rauskam, als wir noch in diesem ganzen Gerüchtewald unterwegs waren.
Wo wir alle nicht auf den Namen iPad gekommen sind.
Wo wir alle nicht auf den Namen iPad gekommen sind, aber ansonsten eigentlich kaum Dinge geäußert haben, die nicht so auch kamen. Also ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, wir haben das Gerät perfekt vorhergesagt, aber die generellen Fragestellungen, die wir uns in dem Moment gefragt haben, wie man es denn anwendet, das waren auch die Fragestellungen, die sich um dieses Gerät dann am laufenden Meter entsponnen haben. Und ich weiß aber noch, einen Kritikpunkt, den ich generell bei dem alten iPad hatte und habe, ist, dass die Rückseite halt nicht flach ist. Das Ding wackelt einfach. Und für mich war das irgendwie absurd, dass etwas, was man Tablett nennt, nicht glatt ist. Also ich kenne kein Tablett, weil es nicht flach ist. Es ist mehr eine Salatschüssel eigentlich als ein Tablett. Also das hat mich irgendwie gestört, weil du musst es eigentlich in so eine Tasche reintun, um es wirklich benutzen zu können. Das ist irgendwie so. Da hat Steve Jobs schon recht. Also man tut das dann da rein und man sieht eigentlich nie, wie hübsch es ist.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich so ein... Also ich meine, das sieht schon, nennt man es beim Wortscheiß auch so in dieser Hülle.
Ich mag die Hülle, weil sie genau das tut, was ich brauche, außer, dass sie keine vertikale Aufstellungsmöglichkeit hat, sondern nur so eine Landscape-Aufstellungsmöglichkeit hat. Das geht auch für das neue Teil. Das zweite, das neue iPad ist flach, und was sie halt auch adressiert haben mit dem neuen iPad durch dieses Smart-Card, sie haben sich jetzt Gedanken gemacht, darum, wie man es aufstellt. Das war meine Aussage am Anfang. Ich dachte mir, wenn schon so ein Tablett, dann muss auch geklärt sein, wie man das Ding hält und steht. Und tatsächlich hat dieses Tragen und Halten und richtig hinstellen, das ist schon... Ärgernis ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben, aber das ist schon ein generelles Problem bei der Benutzung. Laptop steht immer vor einem und leuchtet einen an, und dann kann man mit einem Griff den Bildschirmwinkel einstellen. Beim Tablett musst du halt immer halten oder du musst halt irgendwo draufstellen. Und das funktioniert halt irgendwie nicht. Kein Wunder, dass sie ihre blöden Werbeplakate die ganze Zeit immer nur so gemacht haben, dass das Teil auf dem Schoß lag, weil das ist eigentlich der einzige unbestritten brauchbare Nutzungsort.
Also für mich funktioniert das erstaunlich gut, muss ich sagen. Ich nutze das gerne so eben auf der Couch, liegend quasi, dann dreh ich mich so auf die Seite und leg's dann so ein bisschen hin. Es geht schon mal gucken, ob das mit dem neuen noch so gut geht. Bin ich ja mal sehr gespannt drauf.
Aber leichter ist es.
Aber es hat noch niemand in der Hand gehabt. Wir haben ja auch keinen Apple Store, wo man halt schnell mal hinrennen könnte, um gleich mal die Hardware zu begraben.
Niemand hat gerade einen Apple Store, wo man schnell mal hinrennen könnte.
Aber nicht mal Ausstellungsgeräte?
Doch, die werden sie da haben, oder?
Ja doch, das wahrscheinlich schon. Da kannst du ja angucken, was du alles nicht kaufen kannst. Ja, ja. Ja, es gibt Nachfrage bei dem Gerät, offensichtlich.
Nicht bei mir.
Ich bin nicht wirklich überrascht, aber es ist halt so, dass sie es halt nicht geschafft haben, den Bedarf zu decken. Ob das jetzt bedeutet, dass die Nachfrage groß ist oder sie nicht in der Lage waren, genug zu produzieren. Also so viel sie produzieren wollten eigentlich, weiß ich nicht.
Ich weiß nicht.
Aber ich habe nach wie vor keinen Zweifel daran, dass das iPad 2 noch viel erfolgreicher sein wird, als das erste iPad.
Wie abwegig ist es eigentlich, dass am Anfang der Bedarf noch ein bisschen höher gesetzt wird, indem einfach die Produktion ein bisschen getrosselt wird oder nicht alle Geräte so rausgelassen werden oder sowas? Ich hatte so beim Verizon iPhone hatte ich so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass es so wäre, weil so die richtig langen Schlangen gab es ja da nicht wegen dem Ding.
Weil sie halt Pre-Order gemacht haben. Das habe ich dieses Mal ja nicht.
Na doch, du konntest das.
Genau, das war wahrscheinlich auch die Lehre daraus.
Ich habe kein Pre-Order dieses Mal beim iPad 2-Verkauf.
Achso, aber es könnte schon sein, dass...
Bei Verizon gab es den zwei Wochen vorher.
Jaja, stimmt, jaja.
Aber ich würde schon sagen, dass die auch so ein bisschen das immer genau so managen, dass halt schon genug da ist, aber dann irgendwann auch so dann halt keine mehr. Weil so eine Nachricht ist ausverkauft, ist ja wie Werbung. Das heißt, alle wollen es haben. Das heißt, Produkt ist gut.
Also wie auf jeder Seite draufsteht...
Ja, es ist dann vor, das iPad hätte keine Schlangen erzeugt. Dann würde das sofort direkt neben dem Tsunami steht so, iPad 2 erzeugt keine kilometerlangen Schlangen.
Na, die Sache ist ja, ja, erstens kein Presale und dann vielleicht noch ein bisschen weniger Geräte hinlegen, als man vielleicht schon da haben hätte können. Und dann schubdiwupp.
Aber vielleicht brauchen die ja wirklich eine Weile, um die Produktion hochzufahren oder irgendwie sowas. Also es kann natürlich durchaus sein.
Nee, aber wenn die so einen Termin haben, dann haben die die doch schon vorproduziert, weil am ersten Tag geht es natürlich weg wie nichts. Und dann geht es ja so ein bisschen runter, der Bedarf.
Und es ist das Jahr des iPad 2. Also da kann man schon ein paar auf Halden pro Woche nutzieren.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du die... Weil das Ding muss ja auch noch geheim gehalten werden. Und wenn er in Halb Fox kommt, wenn er 100.000 chinesische Arbeiter dran nur am iPad 2 schrauben, dann ist doch da sicherlich schon mal der eine oder andere geneigt, da mal irgendwie ein kleines paar Details rausrutschen zu lassen. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass die erst am Anfang...
Würdest du es riskieren, dafür, dass du gekillt wirst und deine Familie auch und alle abstämmig von dir?
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das... Ich meine, die Leute arbeiten bei Foxconn. Die haben eher... Doch, ich glaube, das riskieren einige.
Glaube ich nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du das... Das musst du auch geheim halten, das wollte ich sagen. Je mehr du davon im Vorfeld produzierst, desto schwerer ist es, das geheim zu halten. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das schon nicht ganz trivial ist. Also, die werden die Dinge schon vorproduzieren, klar, aber... Ach, was weiß ich.
Also, die bammen dich nicht irgendwie am Tag des Announcements?
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Die müssen es schon eine Woche vorher irgendwann mal loslegen und so.
Klar, aber meinst du nicht, dass die erst mal in einer Fabrik anfangen, so vorsichtig hochfahren und gucken, ob sich das alles produzieren lässt und dann so skalieren, skalieren, skalieren?
Aber ich glaube, der Bedarf ist am Anfang am größten, meinst du nicht?
Zu Weihnachten wird er am größten werden.
Ja, aber dann läuft das ja eh alles schon in Maschinerie und so und dann können sie ja vorher schon richtig loslegen.
Ja, ich glaube so, jetzt sind die, die bestellen die ganzen Fanboys, die können auch ruhig ein bisschen länger warten und dann fährst du so nach und nach die Produktion hoch.
Die Frage ist halt, wie lange dauerte es, ein iPad zu produzieren überhaupt? Oder 100.000 oder eine Million? Vielleicht geht das in einem Tag.
Zeit noch.
Peanuts, iPhones verkaufen so viel in einem Quartal.
Also, ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, verkaufen sie alle 4 Minuten ein iPad? Sie schaffen es nicht ganz, die so schnell zu produzieren, wie sie gekauft werden.
Und wie viele produzieren sie gleichzeitig?
Du, dann nimmst du jetzt die 15 Millionen und teilst hast du...
Also, deine 4 Minuten kann man nicht hinhauen. Du meinst wahrscheinlich 4 Sekunden. Weil 4 Minuten wären 360 iPads am Tag.
Stimmt auch.
4 Minuten wären 160?
Und alle 4 Sekunden sind 20.000 iPads am Tag.
Man kann ja einfach mal 16 Millionen durch 365 teilen.
30 Tage heißt 650.000 im Monat. Das haut schon eher hin. Aber mal 12 kommen wir dann auch gerade mal auf 7 Millionen. Also, das reicht auch nicht, deine 4 Sekunden.
Ich dachte, Steve Jobs hätte so was gesagt. Mit 4 Sekunden. Oder war es nicht Steve Jobs?
Beim iPhone hat er gesagt, 4 iPhones pro Sekunde.
Hier, Chat, jetzt ist eure Gelegenheit kluge Kommentare abzugeben. Übrigens, da jetzt der Chat hier auf dem Beamer läuft, ich bin hier eingeloggt als Metaebene. Und wenn ihr einfach uns auf was Konkretes hinweisen machen wollt, dann macht ihr einfach Metaebene, Doppelpunkt, tralala. Weil dann wird das nämlich hier geheiligtet und dann hab ich eine Chance, das zur Kenntnis zu nehmen. Ich werd mir jetzt nicht hier euren kompletten Chat durchreden.
Jetzt wird gleich alles blau.
Aber kann ich schon mal gleich sagen, was hier mit dem Chat so ein bisschen doof ist? Also man kann ja da schon mitlesen, aber die würfeln natürlich die Themen alle so quer und kreuz durcheinander und stellen schon Fragen und machen und tun, das ist irgendwie schwierig.
Ja, du kannst hier rechts auf dem Twitter gucken, da sind da die klugen Informationen hier, 135.000 iPhone verlassen am Tag.
Das kann ich auch so beim Winkel hier nicht lesen.
Ja, man muss woanders sitzen.
Ja, jetzt hab ich mir den coolen Platz geholt und jetzt ist der Video nicht toll.
Scheiße.
Ich laufe hier zwar Gefahr, vom Beamer erschlagen zu werden, aber dafür kann ich auch das Bild sehen.
Wahrscheinlich muss ich hier doch noch da so ein Fernseher hinhängen und den Beamer dann nach da ausrichten.
Genau, du machst ja dein Bild da selber.
Na dann brauch ich noch einen zweiten iMac. Aber das steht eh noch.
Und noch ungefähr 8 Beamer.
Ja, Foto, Foto ist kommt.
Holodeck, das Podcast Holodeck wollen wir.
So, jetzt muss ich mal hier gucken. Ich hab jetzt gerade das erste Mal versucht, mit Mobile Me was zu publizieren.
Gibt es eigentlich wieder so ein... Aber diesmal haben wir ja gar keine Themen aufgeschrieben, ne?
Doch, ich hab so ein paar aufgeschrieben.
Ist da wieder so ein Pad?
Ne, zum Pad bin ich noch nicht. Ich muss mich jetzt hier gerade um die Bedürftigen im Chat kümmern und denen hier mal ihr Dingsbums geben.
Wie lange kannst du denn dauernd so ein Bild zu twitpicken?
Ich twitte das nicht pick, ich...
Ich picke das twit.
Ich hab das jetzt mal hier auf meine Galerie geschmissen.
Das ist übrigens nicht meine Glatze, was man auf meinem Hinterkopf sieht.
Nein, nein, sondern ein Stück Pizza.
Das ich von Dennis und Huckel versteckt habe.
Jetzt wissen wir endlich, wie die Kilometer eben aussieht.
Das ist gar nicht die ganze Technik hier.
Die ganzen Katakomben sieht man nicht. Man sieht den Mixer und den iMac.
Und das Telefon.
Und die mit Podcast. Und mein MacBook und mein Headset. Ein bisschen was von meinem Stuhl.
Hast du wenigstens noch Location-Daten drin gelassen?
Steht da im Internet.
Wahrscheinlich. Keine Ahnung.
Wenn Tim jetzt abgelenkt ist, können wir mal schnell über Nokia sprechen.
Nokia gibt ein neues Use-Interface. Für Symbian. Ende des Jahres voraussichtlich.
Ende des Jahres Symbian-Interface. Toll.
Wo ist der i9?
Das wäre schön, ich bräuchte noch so einen Cricket-Sound für meine Soundboards.
i9.
iE9.
Das stimmt, das stimmt, das stimmt.
Nobody cares.
Doch, I care. I totally care. Ich find das ja gut.
Ja, ich find das auch gut. Prinzipiell, aber würdest du ihn trotzdem benutzen? Ich vielleicht. Ich find's nicht. Ich fand ja ganz sympathisch, dass sie da diese Seite geschaltet haben mit irgendwie jetzt macht man wirklich diesen iE6 weg, wir wollen jetzt auch nicht mehr, dass ihr den benutzt. und iE9 ist viel cooler und das fand ich ja schon mal einen schönen Zug, irgendwie da die Leute ein bisschen wach zu rütteln und aufzuklären. Und ja, aber trotzdem soll iE9... hab halt kein Windows, ne?
Ja, ich auch nicht.
Stimmt, ich hab sogar ein Windows PC zu Hause.
Zu Hause hast du auch ein Windows PC?
Ich dachte nur auf der Firma.
In erster Linie läuft da XBMC drauf mit Linux, aber ich kann auch null Boot nach Windows machen. Ja, das geht alles.
Ich könnte mir in die Virtual Box, in meine Windows Virtual Box an iE9 installieren. Läuft der auf XP?
Also, Quatsch! Nein, das find ich schon mal ganz gut. Ab Vista brauchste.
Mist, also es ist Mist da. Es ist nicht alles schlecht bei Internet Explorer, glaube ich. Das Interface ist relativ reduziert, das ist ganz angenehm. Aber ansonsten ist er, glaube ich, jetzt nicht so das gelbe vom Ei.
Also er unterstützt halt immer noch nicht viele coole Dinge, oder? Obwohl, oh, sie sagen, es sind drei Tests, 95 von 100 immerhin schon.
Gibt es denn jetzt für McQuarr, oder?
Echt, den erste Test, den können sie noch nicht, den können sie immer noch nicht?
Aber sie können H210, oh nein, ich hab's, oh Gott, nein.
Sie nähern sich auf jeden Fall der HTML5-Welt. Und vor allem sie verwähren sich ihr nicht mehr. Also die Zeiten von Proprietäre Extensions und ActiveX und so weiter, die sind echt vorbei. Und das ist gut.
Da bin ich immer gespannt, ob sie das durchhalten.
Wie heißt denn jetzt diese Engine eigentlich vom E9?
Wies sie nicht? Tasman?
Aber Tasman ist doch schon uralt.
Heißt die immer noch so?
Weil da ist noch sehr viel rot bei Tasman auch.
Ja, so richtig viel geht auch noch nicht. Sie sind extrem stolz auf ihre 3D-Grafikleistung, die sie so können.
Ja klar, die müssen ja immer extrem stolz auf das sein, was die anderen vielleicht noch nicht so cool haben, um sich da zu setzen.
Ja, und da war Chrome vor einem Dreivierteljahr tatsächlich noch ein bisschen langsamer, was das angeht. Aber seitdem haben die ja auch...
Ja, meine 3D ist ja auch jetzt noch nicht so spannend, oder?
Naja, einfach CSS-Beschleunigung und so was, diese ganze Hardware-Beschleunigungsscheiße.
Trident heißt diese Engine.
Da ist doch gerade irgendwie der aktuelle Krieg.
Nein, ich kann nicht weniger.
Wieso? Wenn du CSS-Animationen schön schnell kannst, das ist auch schon was wert. Also ich hab jetzt zum Beispiel... Es gibt dieses Mozilla-Blog, wo so immer so Demos veröffentlicht werden. Und da hab ich gestern auch bei Twitter gepostet. Da haben sie so eine schöne Demo für Firefox 4, was da alles so geht. Und das ist echt eine hübsche Animation, so Typo-Animation, die dann so Schattenspiele macht und so was. Und das ist, in Firefox sieht die echt nett aus. Das ist ein bisschen langsamer. Wenn man das Ganze in Safari oder Chrome off macht, sieht sie den Haar genauso aus, bloß halt in schnell. Und ich glaube, das liegt in erster Linie nicht an JavaScript-Performance, sondern an so 3D-Beschleunigung und so ein Zeug.
Also ich hab ja heute auch so eine Webseite gefunden, die alles so mit CSS-3D-Animations macht.
Das sieht schon geil aus, ne?
Das funktioniert allerdings nur im Webkit Latest in Greatest Schalmer. Ich paste das mal in den Chat. Da können jetzt alle Leute mal mit ihren Browsern ausprobieren.
Yeah, klicken, macht ihn platt, den Jungs.
Der hat halt so einen Webdesigner, der irgendwie doch ganz nette Sachen da so auf seiner Webseite im Portfolio hat. Naja, das mal so am Rande. Also ich weiß nicht, das würde mich mal interessieren, ob zum Beispiel sowas, aber es geht wahrscheinlich nicht im E9. Naja, gut, E9. Ja, in der Wikipedia gibt es ja auch immer diese Comparison-Charts.
Animated CSS-Transform, even in EE. Okay, das ist jetzt aber hier nur so eine...
Naja...
.Z-Transform, das......ist das 3D-Transform?
Also zum iPad 2 haben wir jetzt nichts mehr zu sagen, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich bin ja auch total...
Smart Cover haben wir abgehakt, wir haben ein Bild von der Peter-Ebene gemacht, wir haben über AI9 seine Existenz zur Kenntnis genommen.
Dann können wir Schluss machen, oder?
Dann könnte Dennis jetzt mal über sein neues Gerät berichten.
Wir bitten Herrn Arendts zu Wort.
Er ist jetzt da.
Okay, dann haben wir das abgehakt.
Applaus, Applaus!
Ja, Thunderbolt konnte ich ja noch nicht testen, weil erstens hatte ich kein doppelseitiges Mini DisplayPort Kabel und zweitens hatte mein Kumpel, der...
Doppelseitig?
Ja, wo auf beiden Seiten Mini DisplayPort ist.
Auf beiden Seiten?
Wieso auf beiden Seiten?
Transfer-Disk-Dingsmodus.
Achso, du meinst ja sowas, was ich hier auf dem Tisch liegen hab.
Zum Beispiel, das hier gegangen. Aber es ging nicht, weil von meinem Kumpel, der sich auch einen 15 Zoll bestellt hat, kam das Ding an, der packt es aus, völlig zerkratzt und Tastaturen irgendwie voll im Arsch. In einem Karton, der komplett niegelnagelneu war, also wie bei meinem, aber der Inhalt war irgendwie Schrott. War es auch immer die, die da gemacht haben. Also auch richtig zerkratzt. Also es kann nicht geworfen sein, es muss was Schlimmeres gewesen sein.
Und einen Hund haben sie aber auch gleich anstandslos...
Hat da angerufen, hat gesagt, geht mal gar nicht, hat zurückgeschickt und da jetzt im Urlaub, dauert es noch ein bisschen bis er... Acht.
Weil... Jetzt kommt's....
Apple SSDs sind eh schnallig langsam, die sind sowieso nicht so toll für ihren Preis. Da gibt es bessere und außerdem kamen gerade jetzt zum 1. Mai, kamen neue SSDs raus.
1.
1. März. Und zwar von Intel, die 510 Crest oder so heißt die. Und die macht Lesen oder Schreiben, ich weiß gar nicht. Jedenfalls bis 550 Megabyte die Sekunde. Die musst du an einen SATA 3-Port hängen, sonst kann sie ihre Leistung nicht entfalten. Und die ist sogar noch von Intel, die ist relativ langsam. Es gibt eine noch schnellere von OCZ Vertex 3, auch gerade neu erschienen. Und die macht Lesen und Schreiben über 500.
Ja, ich habe auch gehört, dass diese OCZ gerade ganz gut abgeht, Vertex 3.
Also ich sehe schon, wir driften ein bisschen ab von meinem Laptop, aber es ist egal. Jedenfalls die...
Kannst ruhig mal vertiefen.
Ja, die Intel...
Intel war ja bisher eigentlich immer so mit dem Führungsanspruch unterwegs bei SSDs.
So sieht es aus und weil sie sich auf dem zu viel ausgeruht haben, ist es letztes Jahr ein bisschen eingebrochen, dann wurden sie nämlich überholt, links und rechts. Und zwar von einem Controller, der Sandforce heißt, oder von der Firma Sandforce, ich weiß gar nicht, wie es ist. Und den verbaut auch hier dieses OCZ, diese alte Vertex-Rei hat den auch schon drin. Und der ist ziemlich gut und ziemlich schnell. Und Intel wollte eigentlich auch eine neue rausbringen, neue SSD. Und haben aber gemerkt, mit ihrem eigenen Design, haben sie gegen die Sandforce-Geschichte, haben sie keine Chance. Und was hat Intel gemacht?
Sandforce gekauft?
Nee. Das mit dem eigenen Controller, haben sie gleich mal sein gelassen. Und haben sich den Controller von Marvel lizenziert, oder benutzen den zumindest. Marvel.
Ich glaub, Marvel baut noch keine Controller.
Das sind die, die die Comics machen, wa?
Ja, die machen die Superhelden. Die machen welche bauen.
Die sind so mit einem L und die anderen sind mit zwei L. Ja, dann strahlt's aber.
Egal.
Also, wieder zurück zu den Controllern.
Eigentlich, bis wir jetzt so einen Geigerzähler-Sound einspielen, immer wenn man irgendwie so eine unangemessene Japan-Anspielung gebracht hat.
Ich hab meinen Geigerzähler-Sound an. Den hört man noch nicht, weil hier ist ja nix.
Geigerzähler-Appbook, das ist ein Geigerzähler eingebaut?
Ja klar, die bei Apple haben noch, wie immer, sind die da eurer Zeit voraus.
Aber das Apple II hat noch kein Geigerzähler.
Ich sag euch schon, der nächste Trend, wobei wir jetzt schon wieder ein Thema weiterspringen, bald gibt es Telefone mit eingebautem Geigerzähler.
Ein Kollege von Artcom hat sich von Sparkfun so ein Geiger-Müller-Zählrohr bestellt, als elektronisches Bauteilen baut, gerade ein Accessoire, was man in den Audio-Port vom iPhone stecken kann. Und dann über Audio, was wir auch schon ein paar Mal angesprochen haben, kannst du dann mit so einer kleinen iPhone ab, sozusagen den Geigerzähler auslesen. Dann hast du so ein Trikorder-Feature am Start.
Da geht's ab demnächst. Wieder zurück zu den SSDs.
Wo wir schon beim Abschweifen sind, ich erinnere mich gerade, dass früher, als Chernobyl war vor 25 Jahren, ich bin so ein alter Sackalter, ich bin da schon irgendwie aufrecht rumgelaufen. Und ich hab mir mal einen Spaß gemacht und hab irgendwie, ich weiß nicht mehr was, so ein Stück Elektronik genommen und bin dann irgendwie durch die Stadt gelaufen und immer so und bin den Leuten immer so hinterhergelaufen. Ich war mit so einem Sound völlig verstört.
Achso, du aber auch, oder?
Nee, ich war da völlig verstört. Kann man sich heute gar nicht mehr vorstellen, aber du fingst irgendwie an zu nieseln und alle ranten wie die Blöden.
Kommt bald wieder.
Lass mal die böse Bilder aus. Ja, aber ich sehe jetzt hier gerade auf der OZCZ-Webleite gar keine Vertex 3. Da gibt es nur Vertex 2 für SATA 2.
Ist noch so richtig fresh.
Die Intel gibt es jetzt seit dem 1. März und die OZCZ ist eigentlich auch schon überall im Review und so weiter und das ist gerade das beste Schnellste, was du kriegen kannst. Aber ich bin noch nicht fertig. Ihr habt mich abgelenkt. Und zwar, also Intel hat das wahnsinnige Ding gemacht. Die haben ihren eigenen Controller gedroppt und haben sich den halt von Marvell irgendwie genommen. Den verbauen aber auch viele anderen. Das wäre jetzt nicht so das Alleinstellungsmerkmal. Aber die bei Intel haben eine eigene Firmenwelt drauf, weil das heutzutage, was die Quality von so einer SSD ausmacht, ist gar nicht unbedingt der Controller, sondern halt auch die Firmen, wegen dem ganzen Rear Leveling und Trim Support und was sie alles so machen müssen, damit die Zellen halt möglichst gleichmäßig da beballert werden. Und da ist Intel wohl schon immer noch ganz gut dabei. Und dann ist noch der Unterschied, dass die OCZ, dass die halt Fleisch benutzen, der halt ziemlich klein ist. Also die sind schon bei, keine Ahnung, diese 22 Nanometer oder irgendwie so. War das so? Und Intel nimmt noch die etwas größeren und die sind ein bisschen zuverlässig, weil so kleiner es geht, umso eher ist irgendwie die Chance, dass da auch mal irgendwie ein Bit-Flip, wenn da mal hier so ein Gamma-Strahl ankommt oder irgendwie so was, dann ist es erst so, dann machst du halt mal plopp. Oder wenn wir jetzt gerade aktuell die Sonnenaktivität ein bisschen größer sind und so weiter, keine Ahnung. Jedenfalls da Intel, also wenn es um, wie sagt man, um die Zuverlässigkeit geht, also auch was hier die Ausfallrate insgesamt irgendwie so ausmacht, ist Intel, wo immer noch ziemlich weit vorne, aber sind halt ein ganz bisschen langsamer als diese OCZ. Und die OCZ sind auch deswegen noch so schnell, weil die auch noch Compression mit drin haben. Deswegen kommen die auch noch auf so wahnsinnige Werte. Also alles, was irgendwie nur Nullen und Text und Zeug ist, komprimieren die einfach mal intern irgendwie. Hardware-mäßig wird wegkomprimiert.
Die Vertex 3 2,5 Zoll kann 550 lesen und 525 schreiben, was schon mal schnell ist. Und dann gibt es hier die Intel 510 Series.
Genau, die.
Und die kann 500 lesen und 315 schreiben.
Ja, weil die halt nicht komprimiert. Das heißt bei der OCZ, wenn du da irgendwie deine Movies wegmachst, dann wird da auch nichts mehr komprimiert und dann bricht die natürlich dementsprechend auch ein.
Ja, gut, wenn sie auf 300 einbricht, kann ich damit leben.
Ist so, die bricht halt ungefähr in die Richtung ein, wo die Intel auch ist.
Also ich habe ja diese 512 GB SSD von Apple geliefert, sozusagen die Originale von Apple mit drin, was ja eigentlich eine Toshiba, glaube ich, ist, wenn ich mich recht entsinne.
Ja, aber auch ein bisschen angepasst, glaube ich.
Ja, und die kommt ja so auf so 130, 180 mal lesen und schreiben. Also das ist jetzt sozusagen schon ja echt mehr als doppelt so langsam. Halb so schnell.
Ja, aber man muss jetzt auch dazu sagen, also ich denke mal, ich habe jetzt hier in dem neuen Laptop hier eine MacBook Pro, das ist ja bei uns, ich weiß, okay, auch Toshiba Platte drin, 750 Gigabyte, das heißt, da ist die Dichte ja noch mal höher als an der letzten. Das heißt, wenn die Dichte höher ist, dann lesen die Probedrehungen mehr ein. Das heißt, diese ist auch noch mal dementsprechend schneller. Also ich könnte schwören, die schafft auch locker über 100 oder 110 MB die Sekunde. Aber es ist ja nicht das Entscheidende beim Arbeiten, sondern wichtig ist die Anzahl der Input Output Operations pro Sekunde. Und da toppt eine SSD natürlich, weil die einfach nicht rumzieken muss und irgendwie viel mehr kleine Schreibvorgänge schafft als so eine normale Platte. Genau, also weil sequenziell kann ich mit der Platte hier bestimmt auch 100 MB die Sekunde lesen, aber wenn wir hier irgendwie immer nur drei Byte an irgendwo sonst wo lesen wollen, dann macht der Hoke mich platt mit seiner SSD.
Und alle anderen hier mit SSD auch?
Alle anderen auch und wahrscheinlich sogar der USB Stick. Nein, der nicht, die sind noch zu langsam. Deswegen habe ich erst mal noch nur die Platte drin und werde mir auch irgendwann hier so ein Optibay oder wie immer das Ding heißt kaufen und werde das Laufwerk rausnehmen, werde dort die Festplatte, Quatsch, die Festplatte in den Optibay einbauen und die SSD dahin, wo die Festplatte war, weil nur der Festplattenslot hat SATA 3 bei dem neuen MacBook Pro und da wo die DVD ist, das Laufwerk, das ist nur SATA 2. Aber, good news, Intel hat ja bei diesem Stepping da verkackt mit ihren SATA Ports. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht welches, ich glaube die SATA 2 Ports. Und Apple hat es tatsächlich geschafft, schon dieses neue Stepping zu bekommen.
Es ist wohl mehrfach bestätigt.
Dieser Intel Fail, der da war. Also Apple, die müssen, also Steve hat wahrscheinlich gleich angerufen und hat gesagt, wenn hier nicht sofort die neuen Stepping da sind, dann...
Was meinste denn mit Stepping?
Der Chipset bei Intel hatte irgendwie einen Fehler und die haben ja verschiedene Stepping. Das heißt, wenn die ein Bug fixen in ihre Hardware, dann kriegt das ein neues Stepping.
Version in Hardware sozusagen.
Genau, das ist Stepping. Und das alte hieß B2 und das neue Stepping heißt B3. Und Apple hat schon irgendwie das B3 Stepping. Obwohl es erst eigentlich Ende März, Ende Februar rauskommen sollte. Und mein Gerät wurde definitiv ein paar Tage vorher produziert. Also das heißt, Apple muss wirklich einer der Ersten sein, die da sich...
Die haben das einfach in der Zeitmaschine gepackt und so. Das hat irgendwie einen Tsunami ausgelöst.
Aber Hauptsache, die Rechnung ist hier schnell genug da.
Jo, so viel dazu. Ja und ansonsten, also bei mir kann ja... Also bei mir hört es ja gar nicht mehr auf an den Vorteilen gegenüber meinem alten. Also ich hatte ja in meinem Core zwei Duo von für vier Jahren. Der Speicher war nicht so viel, nur 3 Gig anstatt 8. Nicht so schnell war der Speicher. Grafik war tausendfach langsamer.
Aber 8 ist Max, ne?
Ja, aber es gibt ja auch noch keine größeren, oder? Also ich denke mal, hier gehen wahrscheinlich auch größere... Also wenn es der neueste Chipset drin ist, dann gehen da bestimmt auch schon mehr rein.
Achso, du meinst nur eine Frage der Verfügbarkeit von den größeren Modulen?
Apple hat doch schon immer nur das angegeben, was gerade verfügbar ist.
Ja, hast du recht.
Nee, aber sonst ist es super cool. Im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, weil ich benutze ja auch die größere Version. 1680, aber in Glossy, weil ich ja so ein Optik-Freak bin. Und ich hab dieses SMC-Fellkopf voll am Start. Jedenfalls läuft der jetzt gerade hier mit 37 Grad. Und mein altes Powerbook, Rotsmodul, hat immer so 50. Also der läuft wesentlich kühler. Da gibt's ja Leute, die meinen, der würde so heiß werden. Kann ich bisher nicht bestätigen.
So ein Podcaster finanzieren, indem sie leben von dem Geld, was in einer schlechten Portspielkasse drin entfällt.
Was ich noch probiert hab, ist...
Mein R ist gerade auf 42.
Dann kannst du mal sehen. 35 hat sogar nur das Gesunken. Hat einer wahrscheinlich gerade, haben sie zu wenig gechattet. Jedenfalls habe ich 2001 einen Blu-ray-Film, den ich mir mal gekauft hab, gerapt auf allen vier Chors. Und der Lüfter ging nicht auf irgendwie, der geht jetzt bis 6200 anstatt 6000, so wie früher.
Es gibt ja Blu-ray-Laufwerke, die auch an Mac anzuschließen sind, über USB und was nicht noch alles.
Genau so war es.
Und es gibt ein Programm... Und es gibt so, tatsächlich habe ich kürzlich gesehen, ein Programm Mac Blu-ray Ripper Pro, die haben auch schon Mac DVD Ripper Pro gemacht. Und die haben hier ein Ripper-Programm für Blu-ray und das muss ja dann scheinbar mit externen Blu-ray-Laufwerken funktionieren.
Jetzt, wo du sagst, ich genau so habe es gemacht.
Das kann man sich schwer merken. Mac Blu-ray Ripper Pro ist halt auch schon echt ein langer Name.
Jedenfalls habe ich das gemacht und ich habe es nicht geschafft, den Lüfter auf 6200 Umdrehungen zu bringen, sondern der ist so bei 4,5 bis 5 ist irgendwie stehen geblieben. Dann dachte ich, wenn ich irgendwie den 2001 Ripper zum Testen, dann gucke ich nebenbei noch irgendwie einen anderen HD-Film, so 1080p und das ging immer noch nicht hoch. Also nur alleine durch CPU vollballern, kriegst du diesen Lüfter nicht auf volle Pille. Du musst schon die Grafikkarte mit beanspruchen. Dann geht es irgendwie. Oder vielleicht, wenn es ein bisschen wärmer ist im Sommer, schafft man es dann vielleicht. Aber jetzt hier so war da keine Chance. Absolut unglaublich. Super.
Ich will trotzdem kein MacBook Pro mehr.
Ja, weil es jetzt so groß ist.
Was mir zu schwer ist.
Ich find's okay.
Also wenn es flacher wär.
Ich hab ja auch rausgestellt, dass MacBook Pro eher Pro rauskommt, aber war ja leider nicht. Jetzt muss ich halt hier mit der Kiste leben.
512K.
Da fällt mir übrigens gerade so ein, als kleiner Tipp, weil es heute schon an mir vorbei skollte, Makeupdate, nach dem Version-Tracker ist jetzt tot. Oder? Die haben wir irgendwann nicht gemacht. Ach, gibt's die gar nicht mehr? Ich glaube nicht. Aber Makeupdate ist ja immer noch da. Und Makeupdate hat auch so was Ähnliches wie Mac heißt. Also immer mal so Promo-Bundles. Und da gibt's gerade ein neues Bundle. Und da gibt's zum Beispiel Parallels Desktop, One Password und MacDVD Ripper 2, Hands Off, was wir hier auch schon besprochen hatten, und so ein paar andere Programme, die man vielleicht braucht oder nicht, für 49 Dollar für die nächsten 14 Tage.
Ich hab überlegt, ob ich deswegen Hands Off mache und hier Parallels, das ist ja schon...
Ich paste das mal in den Chat.
Das ist nicht Mac heißt, das ist...
Das hab ich schon ein paar Mal nämlich verpasst und da waren eigentlich coole Programme drin. Na gut, jetzt interessiert es mich eigentlich gerade nicht, aber vielleicht findet ja der ein oder andere noch... Was möglich ist da drin.
Wenn man kein One Password hat, dann ist das eine gute Gelegenheit.
Ich hab kein One Password, aber ich trau dem auch nicht.
Was mir noch aufgefallen ist bei mac.co ist, dass der Kernel schon einer von 10.6.7 ist.
Ja, das ist ja nicht überraschend, oder?
Ja, aber das Thema selbst meldet sich noch als 10.6.6, aber der Kernel ist schon 10.6.7.
Und 64-Bit?
Und 64-Bit, genau.
Aber ich mein, das ist doch immer so, wenn ein neues Gerät rauskommt, ist immer eine leicht gepitchte Version von der aktuellen Version. Seit Ewigkeiten so.
Und Jungs, ich muss verkünden, meine beiden Platten, ich habe das System und Datenplatte, die heißen jetzt... Ich hab jetzt mir mal was Neues einfach...
Bomo Zack.
Nee, vorher hießen ja Pussy und Galore. Und dachte ich, jetzt muss ich noch was Neues her, vor allem, weil ich meinen alten Rechner ja auch noch hab. Und deswegen hab ich jetzt Honey und Rider. Weil nämlich aus dem ersten James Bond Goldfinger, so heißt nämlich jetzt auch mein Rechner, hieß ja die Tante aus dem Wasser, Ursel Andres hieß ja Honey Rider. Muss man ja mal gesagt haben.
Pussy Galore war die Tante, die Pilotin.
Genau. Honor Blackman hieß die.
Dann hast du auch Honey und Bunny nennen können.
Nee, das wär ja Pulp Fiction.
Naja.
Ich meine, wenn man die Wahl hat zwischen James Bond und Pulp Fiction...
Aber wenn er jetzt nun seinen Namenschema auf James Bond-Filme gelegt hat, also oder auf Frauen aus James Bond-Filmen, das ist doch ein legitimes Nachschema.
Frauen aus James Bond, das heißt Bond Girls.
I'm sorry. So, jetzt müssen wir alle wie Dennis Festplatten heißen. Ist das nicht ein bisschen intim, um so ein Podcast zu erzählen?
Meine heißen Macintosh HD.
Also ich hab auch da immer so einen Kult rausgemacht, lange Zeit, und ich hab's auch früher aus Prinzip meinen Festplatten immer Namen gegeben, wo ein Space drin ist.
Um rauszukriegen, damit nicht klar kann, welche Programme.
Ich hab jetzt eine, ich hab im Ausrufezeichen ein schlechtes Software gleich ausgefiltert.
Mit Leuten, mit diesen PTs, darauf starren und sich fragen, wie denn das sein kann. Das ist eine Festplatte. Also ein Lehrzeichen. Ich bin da in der Teilnahme. Ich hab auch immer sehr auf Umlaute Wert gelegt.
Also meine Festplatte ist immer Bösekuh. Und die aktuelle heißt jetzt Timmy Ausrufezeichen.
Timmy?
Timmy.
T-I-N-G-Y. Wirklich? Du hast deine Festplatte nach mir benannt?
Die war ja ganz neu, als ich zur Aufnahme kam. Und dann hat Huckel. Mach mal, du kannst das so.
Ich kann das auch nicht richtig. Ich suche mal einen Sound-Snip, bitte.
Nach der Aufnahme bin ich in einer Volldarkose.
Ich hab die Platten immer so Amazing Glory oder so was genannt.
Nach Pornotiteln oder was?
Nee, einfach so, was mir in dem Moment so einfiel.
Und wie heißt sie aktuell?
Mittlerweile bin ich da ein bisschen zurückhaltender geworden. Ich weiß gar nicht warum. Ich bin jetzt wahrscheinlich auch durch Raumzeit so ein bisschen in so einem Space-Meme. Also mein aktueller Rechner heißt Antares.
Was ist denn Antares? Offensichtlich nicht irgendein Stern.
Ich werde gerade auf einen Fehler hingewiesen im Chat. Ich hab irgendwas mich verkackt. Und zwar bei Honey Rider, das ist ja gar nicht Goldfinger. Das ist ja wirklich Dr. Novi. Ich bin nicht auf Goldfinger gekommen. Aber bei Goldfinger etwa Pussygalore. Das könnte sein. Bei Goldfinger war das Pussygalore, ne?
Ja, definitiv.
Jetzt müsste ja mein Rechner Dr. No nennen, oder? Nee, das geht aber nicht.
Wieso ist da immer noch James Bond? Aber Honey Rider stimmt doch. Ach so, warte mal, dein Rechner?
Den hab ich jetzt Goldfinger genannt.
Ja, dann musst du den umbenennen jetzt.
Na nee, ist mir jetzt egal. Ich lass das jetzt so.
Honey Chile Rider heißt es eigentlich. Honey Chile.
Ja, da hätte ich aber auch den richtigen Namen genommen.
Ach so, im Film haben sie es gekürzt auf Honey. Und im Buch ist es Honey Chile.
Klingt ja wirklich furchtbar.
Kannst du ja auch einfach Ursula Andres nennen. Oder dicke Titten.
Ich hab mal gehört, so viele geile Bond-Göllen-Namen gibt es auch gar nicht.
Hornofilm-Namen.
Da kenn ich mich nicht aus.
Okay, ich kann dich da auf eine Spur führen, aber das gelingt mir jetzt wohl nicht. Okay, wir werfen 5 Euro in die Showy-Kasse und vielleicht sollten wir mal wieder über Macs reden.
Haben wir noch über, Dennis Mac haben wir die ganze Zeit gerade gelesen.
Und wie er ihn besser nennen sollte.
Ja, also flotter, schneller, besser, breiter, heller. LED ist total cool, LED schon, aber genau früher konnte man, ich weiß nicht ob es bei deinem noch so ist, mal kurz klicken hier bei Huckel. Ja bei Huckel ist es so, dass wenn man die Taste für dunkler und heller klickt, dann macht der Bildschirm, weil es halt die LED ist, die so schnell ist, macht so Klick, Klick, Klick, so in harten Stufen. Wenn man das bei mir macht, dann dimmt er das. Der dimmt das, genau. Also du klickst und dann macht es so langsam, wird es heller und dunkler. Das ist nicht so schlagartig.
Oh mein Gott, ich muss mir auch eins kaufen.
Weil ich immer noch sehr unzufrieden bin mit diesem ganzen...
Und man kann es ziemlich dunkel machen, was ziemlich cool ist, wenn wir wieder Kino machen irgendwo, dann kann man es schön runter regeln. Das ist nicht schlecht.
Ja, mir fehlt da auch noch mindestens eine Stufe zwischen dunkelsten Licht an und aus.
Immer schon war das.
Und bei der Lautstärke auch.
Vorsicht.
Das ist jetzt hier die dunkelste Stufe für unsere Zuschauer. Muss man sagen, es ist einfach fast schwarz.
Das stimmt, das sieht schon relativ dunkel aus.
Es geht nicht so dunkel.
Das scheinen sie gerade ein bisschen erinnern zu haben.
Ja, hatten sie auch, haben sie irgendwo. Stand das mal schon bei irgendwelchen Geräten. Und ansonsten Stromverbrauch. Ich glaube, mein altes MacBook Pro, kurz weil du war, bei 20 Watt oder irgendwie so. Und das jetzt hier in der dunkelsten Stufe ist irgendwie bei 12 mit der internen Grafikkarte.
Wie misst du das?
Mit so einem Strommesser.
Mit vollgeladenem Akku sozusagen.
Aber hallo. Ich hab bisher noch überhaupt gar nicht mein Ding mit Batterie benutzt seit letzter Woche. Ist ja überall Strom, ist ja nicht wie in Japan hier.
Doch.
Klingelingeling.
Die Kommentare hast du alle dann zu beantworten.
Das wird heiß hergehen in den Kommentaren.
Kochen wird's da.
Die Kommentarschmelze.
So, jetzt krieg ich hier gerade widersprüchliche Kommentare rein.
Nee, das, äh, wie Steven Colbert in seiner Press-Conference in der Ansprache auch schon meinte, straight from the gut. Don't look it up in the book. Hab ich letztens auch mal wieder gesehen und fand ich ja tatsächlich auch immer noch ganz großartig. Da hat er auch nachträglich diverse Balls of Steel-Awards gewonnen, einfach für... Nee, da wo er neben Bush auf der Bühne steht, beim Press-Conference-Dinner und ihn so richtig runterputzt.
Das kennst du nicht?
Ich hab nur so ein paar Sekunden, glaub ich mal, ich hab's nie komplett gesehen.
Das muss man sich wirklich mal komplett anschauen. Also Colbert beim Presidents-Dinner, das ist einfach mal...
Der Knaller.
Also dieser Ricky Gervais, der hier die komischen Film-Awards letztens gemacht hat und da auch über die Stars hergezogen ist, das war schon ganz lustig, aber der Colbert haut da nochmal wirklich ein paar...
Ja vor allem als der Presse so eingeseift.
Was man aber auch gucken sollte ist, wie John Stewart bei...
Tim O'Reilly.
Ja, ja, das ist auch der Klassiker.
John Stewart bei Crossfire. Und wenn man dann schon dabei ist, dann kann man auch gucken...
John Stewart bei Crossfire hat sich auch...
Ich glaube, Frank Zappa bei Crossfire.
Das hab ich sogar mal auf Chaos TV gepostet. Das war, glaub ich, auch Crossfire.
Den Frank Zappa, den mag ich eigentlich nicht so.
Da guckst du dir das Video an und dann liebst du ihn, weil der Typ bringt es einfach mal auf den Punkt.
Aber die Musik mag ich trotzdem nicht.
Vielleicht machst du es danach.
It's just words. Darum geht es auch, diese ganze Zensurdebatte und irgendwie Porno und überhaupt Filzi und so weiter. Und der sitzt da und sagt, Leute, es sind Worte. Worüber reden wir hier? Guck mal, klar. Echt großartig. Ja, nachdem wir jetzt wieder etwas abgeschweift sind, sonst hätte mal hier keiner mangelnde Bandbreite vorwerfen können.
16?
Wir brauchen hier noch ein Klingelgeräusch für die Wortsprichkasse.
Tim muss jetzt mal was sagen, sonst pennt er ein.
Ah, ja.
Ja, ich bin müde. Ich hab heute schon...
Spitz zum wiederholten Male und ich branele das an.
Soll ich einfach übernehmen? Hawaii 50 übernehmen sie? Oder 05? 05?
Ich guck jetzt erst mal, was die Zettelbutton sagen.
Ich könnte jetzt ein bisschen Zetterfess erzählen.
Erzähl mal ein bisschen Zetterfess.
Irgendwie, ich glaub gestern hab ich's irgendwie getwittert. Da gibt's ne Bude, die heißt... Wie heißt die jetzt? Genau. Die haben... Ich hab das ja erst nicht geglaubt. Das wär irgendwie ein Schwachsinn. Hab da ein bisschen hinterher gegoogelt. Und zwar, die meinen, dass sie hier schon am Beta testen, von einem Zetterfess für OSX sind. Das Ding heißt... Z410 oder wie nennen die das? Ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau. Ich muss mal kurz gucken. Und es heißt, wo heißt es hier? Z410 und wenn man es halt mal ausspricht, dann heißt es Z410. Und OSX halt. Irgendwann dachte ich, das kann ja nichts Gutes sein. Das sind vielleicht die Freaks, die da die Open Source Versionen da bei Google irgendwie... bei Google Code irgendwie zusammengeschustert haben. Ist aber nicht der Fall, sondern der Typ, der das macht. Don Brady ist der ehemalige Apple ZFS Programmierer. Und zwar hat der mit dieser Noelle Dellafano zusammen das ZFS, äh... bei Apple portiert. Und der ist da wohl ausgestiegen, weil es heißt, dass er ein former Apple Senior Software Engineer ist. Also ist er da wohl nicht mehr. Und vielleicht hat er ja... ist er da ausgestiegen und hat halt diese Bude aufgemacht. Und weil er sich dachte, wenn Apple das nicht macht, dann macht er das selber. Und bringt jetzt ZFS raus. Und was ich so gelesen hab von irgendwelchen Beta-Testern, das ist wirklich die Top-Notch-Version, die sie bei FreeBSD gerade haben. Also ist Version 28 schon mit D-Duplication und D-Z3-Support. Also mit Triple... also ist nicht irgendein alter Scheiß, sondern sie sind wirklich ganz vorne mit dabei. z410.tenscomplement.com z410.tenscomplement.com Ja, da steht auch nicht viel mehr, außer dass sie die Beta-Phase da haben. Und die war aber nach ein paar Stunden war ihr Kontingent dafür schon weg. Ist fast ähnlich wie beim Kongress.
Das ist natürlich wirklich cool. Ich meine mir wär's natürlich noch viel lieber, wenn Apple das mal richtig einbauen würde. Zumal mir auch noch Zweifel gekommen sind bezüglich meiner Einschätzung von der letzten Sendung.
Die wäre welche?
Na, ich hab doch so allerlei Gemutmaß darüber, wie dieses Time Machine und wie das sich so im HFS Plus so wiederfindet. Ich muss zugeben, ich hatte jetzt eigentlich nahezu keine Zeit, mich irgendwie mit Linen auseinanderzusetzen in den letzten zwei Wochen. Aber es fiel auf, dass bei Geräten, die Linen liefen Prozesse, wie hieß das noch gleich? Dieses MTMFS, also Mobile Time Machine Fallsystem, da probier ich das mal und da gibt es dann auch noch einen passenden Demon dazu. Den MTMD oder so was, weiß nicht ganz genau, Agent irgendwas, der halt verdächtig viel CPU zwischenzeitlich sich mal einverleibt hat. Also da läuft irgendein MTM Prozess. Das ist jetzt wieder reines Lesen aus dem Gemüsebeet, aber das macht auf mich dann so den Eindruck, dass meine Hoffnung, Einschätzung will ich es gar nicht mal nennen, dass es sich hier wirklich so über ein Fallsystem Feature handelt und diese Snapshots quasi automatisch erzeugt werden, aber durch diesen virtuellen Blick dieses Volumes, dieses Mobile Backups quasi nur als Fallsystem Struktur sichtbar werden, dass das unter Umständen gar nicht so ist und tatsächlich lokal denselben Hardlinking Backup Scheiß macht, wie er das eben auf einer Time Machine Platte auch macht. Ich weiß nicht, was heißt höchst wahrscheinlich, beides ist vorstellbar. Nachdem ich jetzt diesen Prozess da hab rumwumpeln sehen, dachte ich mir so, okay, alles klar, vielleicht ist es doch nicht so toll.
Na gut, aber kann man nicht sagen, wenn er noch die Bug-Information drin hat und zwischendurch mal irgendwie...
Ja, aber wenn es keine wirklichen, echten, nativen Snapshots gibt in diesem Fallsystem, stellt sich mir immer wieder diese Frage, was ist ein Snapshot? Ich meine, wenn er 5 Minuten braucht, um das Fallsystem durchzufügen, um so einen Snapshot zu erzeugen, welchen Stand haben wir denn? Am Anfang der 5 Minuten oder am Ende der 5 Minuten? Also welche Daten, die gerade heftig geschrieben werden, da hast du sowas, was ich, Beton-Downloads laufen, Programme schreiben, komplex vorne und hinten in ihre Dateien rein, oder aktualisieren so einen kompletten Tree. Und mitten in diesem Tree-Update irgendwo fummelt er dann irgendwie sich Dateien in das Backup, die irgendwie...
Ja, aber das kannst du bei ZFS, wenn du sagst, mach jetzt einen Snapshot, kannst du auch haben, wenn das mittendrin bei irgendeinem Prozess ist, dann bist du da genau in der Hälfte. Die Einzigen, die was dagegen gemacht haben, ist Microsoft, die haben irgendwie eine API, wo man noch so seine Snapshot, wo man steuern kann, dass es jetzt hier bitte beim Schreiben nicht mittendrin passiert, sondern erst davor oder danach.
Das stimmt. Nee, ist nicht so easy, aber ich meine, wenn ich zumindest sagen kann, jetzt will ich einen Snapshot haben, dann geht es auch instantan, sofort.
Wahrscheinlich wird das gar nicht so das große Problem werden, weil die meisten Programme, also es ist ja in Ersten Jahr wahrscheinlich für Daten gedacht und Fotos und so und Scheiß und nicht für dein Gesamtsystem. Und jetzt mit Line kommt ja sowieso dieses, dass die Versionierung direkt im App geregelt wird, also im Programm und in dem Moment, in dem der sagt, Speicher legt er halt eine neue Version an davon.
Ja gut, ich meine, da werden noch glaube ich noch viel Wasser in die Flüsse runtergehen, bis wir das sehen, dass alle Programme das unterstützen. Und ich kann dir gleich zehn Software-Hersteller sagen, die es in ihrem Leben nie unterstützen werden.
Natürlich, klar wird es die geben.
Also nicht Microsoft, nicht Adobe, nicht Ableton, keine Audio-Software außer Logic.
Tja, nicht mal die wahrscheinlich.
Vielleicht noch nicht mal die, ja. Wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal Final Cut Pro. Ja, wobei, ich glaube das nächste Final Cut Pro, das ist dann schon...
Ja, lange könnt ihr nicht mehr...
Ein fettes Coco 64-Bit-Update. Die lassen sich ja auch gerade verdammt viel Zeit. Wie lange ist Final Cut Pro nicht mehr aktualisiert worden?
Naja, auf jeden Fall, also es wäre... Naja, also so ein bisschen... Also ich finde es ja schon nach wie vor immer ein bisschen dünne, dass sie da auf ihrem Half-S Plus rumreiten und sollte dann bei John Siracusa nicht irgendwie in seinem In-Death-Review rauskommen, dass jetzt Half-S Plus mega krass aufgebohrt wurde, dann ist das immer noch so eins der großen Mangel.
Nee, ich glaube, die haben genau gar nichts gemacht an dem File-System.
Na, für Encryption müssen sie zumindest irgendwas dran gemacht haben. Also das ist nicht der Stand...
Müssen sie nicht?
Doch.
Müssen nicht. Kommt drauf an, wie sie es gemacht haben. Aber eigentlich ist es ja das Blog-Device da drunter und das wird halt gekryptet und was du da drüber fährst, ist doch das.
Ja, aber sie machen das in-place zur Laufzeit. Ja, ohne auf doppeltem Platz zu greifen. In-place.
Aber zum Beispiel bei FreeBSD gibt es ja auch dieses Geom und da kannst du auch sagen, hier mein Blog-Device ist hier mit diesem Eli-Encryption-Tralala irgendwie, dann ist dein Blog-Device einfach entkryptet und dein Fallsystem machst du oben drüber und das Fallsystem weiß gar nicht, dass es auf so einem Krypto-Device drauf ist.
Ich verstehe, dass man das auf so einem Geometrie-Level noch eingezogen hat.
Genau, so ein Zwischenlayer. Was sie bei ZFS hält, um mal wieder zum ZFS zu kommen, nicht gemacht haben, werden die Krypto machen und die haben auch Krypto jetzt nicht bei der Version, die sie jetzt hier auch für Mac portieren. Bei Freebidders haben sie es auch noch nicht, aber bei OpenSolaris, da ist sozusagen das Krypto direkt ins Fallsystem integriert.
Hat mal jemand probiert, so eine entkryptete HFS Plus-Platte an 10.6 anzuschließen?
Das wird nicht mal gefunden, das hab ich gesehen.
Das spricht natürlich für deine Theorie, weil wenn sie bei der Umstellung von HFS auf HFS Plus, wie sie da vorgegangen sind, mit dieser plötzlich ReadMe-Datei, die dann existiert und so was, da haben sie also ein Dateisystem ins andere gepackt und wenn sie jetzt hier darauf verzichtet haben, dann wird das ja sicherlich ein Problem haben.
Ich würd mich nicht wundern, wenn jetzt in 10.6.7 des Disk Utility Tool auch schon die neueren Partitionen, diese Krypto-Partitionen oder Filesysteme, wie sie auch immer dieses gelöst haben, wenn es das dann erkennt und ordentlich anzeigen kann. Weil jetzt ist ja die Katze aus dem Sack, jetzt weiß es ja jeder und dann können sie es auch in die Disk Utility mit reinschmeißen. Aber es ist wohl auch keine Full-Disk-Encryption, sondern es ist eigentlich eine Partitionsweite-Encryption. Also du kannst ja zwei Partitionen auf einer Platte haben und die eine ist gekryptet und die andere nicht.
Also du sagst, es ist nur die Partitionen-Encrypte auf jeden Fall?
Naja, was heißt nur?
Also es ist auf Partitionsgröße. Also es muss nicht die ganze Platte sein. Ja, war schon wieder ein bisschen mehr für so eine Filesystem-seitige Encryption spricht, aber das können die so oder so gemacht haben. Am Ende nimmt sich das, glaube ich, aber auch nicht wirklich viel, oder?
Wie sieht das eigentlich aus? Habt ihr mal mit diesem AirDrop rumgespielt?
Na ja, nur solo und da ist es ein bisschen witzlos. Hatten wir in der letzten Sendung schon erzählt, hatten wir angemacht, aber da dann keine Zweitgeräte mit AirDrop am Start waren.
Was ich ja ein bisschen nicht verstanden habe bei diesem AirDrop, ist ja, als ich es zum ersten Mal gehört habe, ich dachte, wenn irgendwie zwei Rechner, so wie bei uns hier, sind alle jetzt hier im gleichen Netzwerk, dass ich dann irgendwie den Timme bei mir sehe, was bei ihm raufschmeißt, er das bei sich kriegt, und dann kann er sich kopieren. Aber wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe, dann ist es so, da können sich zwei wildfremde Menschen mit ihren Laptops auf der Straße treffen und die machen beide AirDrop an und deren WLAN-Treiber, was auch immer, also die finden sich so automatisch.
Du musst nicht mal am selben WLAN sein.
Die müssen nicht mal am selben WLAN sein und sie werden aber trotzdem gefunden. Das unterstützt aber auch nur die neuesten WLAN-Treiber. Mit irgendwelchen älteren Geräten ging es wohl irgendwie nicht. Meinten welche, da muss man halt nochmal gucken. Jedenfalls erzeugen sie dann selbstständig irgendwie so ein Ad-hoc-Netzwerk und linken sich da beide ein und legen da los und dann wird kopiert.
Klingt mir ehrlich gesagt eine Lösung, die ich so mehr auf einem iOS-Device sehe als auf einem MacOS.
Eigentlich schon, aber ich finde, wenn man so mit jemandem was tauscht, dann ist man doch sowieso meistens im gleichen Netz, oder?
Naja, aber dann so eine Lösung zu machen, die wahrscheinlich macht es dir auch entsprechend leichter, wenn du sowieso schon im gleichen Netz bist. Aber dann zu sagen, das klappt in jeder Situation, das ist doch super und dann wird das mit dem iPad hoffentlich irgendwann auch mal funktionieren und mit iPhone und dann...
Oder vielleicht gerade mit dem Rechner zu so einem iOS-Gerät, also weil die Daten kommen ja meist nicht.
Genau, dann kündige ich noch dein iPhone an, dass es einen Hotspot drinne hat und du kannst einfach so sagen, hier, mach mal per AirDrop Hotspot Verbindung auf, wär schon ganz cool.
Naja, aber haben wir nicht weiter ausgetestet, aber...
Ich hab's mir so kurz angeguckt.
Hört sich interessant an.
Aber nicht so richtig extrem lange.
Eigentlich kam heute noch mal so eine kleine Neuigkeit, dass es halt diesen Airport-Monitor geben soll, der irgendwie, oder ich weiß nicht, ob es gestern schon kam, ich hab's heute erst gesehen, der irgendwie ganz interessant aussah. Natürlich jetzt auch nicht wieder für jeden, sondern eher für die Nerd-Fraktion. Aber sah erstmal ganz schick aus. Na, hat jemand in Lion gefunden. Also du klickst halt mit ALT oben auf das Wi-Fi-Icon jetzt. Und da gab's ja dann früher immer schon so die BSS-IDs und das alles. Und jetzt gibt's da eine zusätzliche Option, Airport-Monitor. Und da zeigt er dir dann an, so die Kurven von Empfangsstärke und so mit schicken Grafen und sah ganz schnuffig aus.
Da muss man nur mit dem ALT reingehen, meinste?
Ja, mit ALT kommen wir ja schon jetzt ein bisschen mehr oder deutlich mehr Informationen.
Ja, aber da soll's unten so eine Option geben, dann in diesem Menü. Ähm, Monitor, Airport-Monitor. Ich such's gerade hier auf MacStories, aber find's gerade gar nicht.
Ich hab das heute bei, wie heißt das, Apple Insider, glaube ich, gelesen.
Oder war's auf Apple Insider? Suchen wir doch mal mit Apple F.
Genau, da. Inside Mac OS X, Lion New Wi-Fi Diagnostic Tool.
Dann war's auf Apple Insider. Ja, und hast du das, Tim?
Was muss man da klicken? Alter, Wi-Fi Diagnostics.
Auf den Schirm!
Mhm, das ist auf dem kleinen Schirm.
So, kurze Pause, das schneidet Tim dann mal raus.
Macht so Linien.
Aber das heißt, die waren am WLAN dran? Wenn sie sowas jetzt plötzlich auslesen, so diese ganzen Qualitätsmerkmale, das heißt, die waren da mal ein bisschen tiefer wieder dran, würde ich jetzt mal behaupten.
Ich glaube, das ist bei jedem US-Release da ein bisschen tiefer dran.
Ich dachte jetzt, das passt gut zu dieser AirDrop-Theorie.
Ja, was hat jetzt AirDrop mit Airport zu tun?
Weil das neue WLAN-Features nutzt. Und Dennis doch gerade gesagt hat, dass es nur mit den neuesten Treibern funktioniert und nicht mit älteren WLAN-Treibern. Und dass da offensichtlich der WLAN-Treiber ein bisschen für vorbereitet sein muss und dass da das vielleicht unten rausgefallen ist, als sie da schon mal dran waren. Verstehe.
Haben sie noch in die Grafikkiste gepackt und jetzt sieht es schick aus.
Hier fällt Majed ab. Und, ach hier, guck mal, jetzt gibt es auf dem Beamer auch die...
Ach, jetzt haben wir auch Themen.
Jetzt haben wir auch Themen. Trim auch in 1066 wohnen.
Ja, aber nur für die Apple SSDs selbst halt, weil die haben es wohl noch nötig, weil da die Firma wahrscheinlich scheiße ist.
Ja, aber bei mir gibt es das nicht noch.
Ist Trim jetzt plötzlich mehr doof, oder was?
Nein, Trim ist nicht doof. Trim ist eigentlich ganz okay. Das ist schon genau der richtige Ansatz, aber...
Trim Support? No. In Lion hatte ich da Trim Support, yes, aber hier auf meinem 1066 gerade, oder? Ja, aber...
Wo hast du deinen Rechner her?
Ich glaube nur, wenn es neu damit ausgeliefert wird.
Ist das über Apple bestellt?
Also ich glaube, das ist jetzt bei den neuen MacBook-Pos.
Ich bin nicht von so einem Zwischenhändler.
Doch, Kindcom.
Vielleicht hast du keine Apple SSD drin, weil du Apple SSD Preise bezahlt hast, und die haben dann die billige da eingebaut.
Jetzt hast du es versehentlich schneller.
Hast du eine SSD?
Zeig mal. Apple SSD TS512B. Hätte ja sein können. Wahrscheinlich kommt das dann mit 1067 oder mit 107 halt.
Also nochmal zu deiner Frage, Max. Das Trimme ist schon ganz cool, aber die moderneren Firmen, wer sind diesen Controllern, die machen das halt selber. Also wenn du da einen Blog schreibst, dann nehmen sie einen, der noch unbelegt ist. Also sag mal, du willst als File-System, du willst einfach irgendwelche Daten in einem Blog 1000 schreiben. Dann haben die ja so einen virtuellen Layer dazwischen, die schreiben das halt bei sich irgendwo auf irgendeinen Blog, der halt frei ist auf der SSD. Wissen aber, dass der logische Blog 1000, dass du den gerade überschrieben hast und können den deswegen löschen.
Ja, aber wenn ich jetzt einfach...
Und löschen ihn dann irgendwann?
Aber wenn ich jetzt meine Platte sozusagen, wenn ich jetzt... Ich hab die Platte zur Hälfte belegt oder... Meine Platte ist voll und ich schmeiß jetzt einfach die Hälfte der Daten wieder runter, dann könnt ihr mit Trim Support, so einer SSD, wisst ihr Bescheid, alles klar, die Daten und die Daten und die Daten, da brauch ich mich gar nicht drum zu kümmern. Du hast doch Trim da.
Ne, Trim ist dafür da. Eine SSD braucht beim... Also die können nicht einfach so einen Block beschreiben, sondern die müssen den erst löschen. Dieses Löschen dauert halt ein bisschen. Deswegen will man möglichst schon vorher gelöscht haben. Aber vorher zu löschen, müsste man wissen, dass der Block nicht belegt wird. Bei Trim sagt man, ok, wenn du ein Pfeil löscht, dann schickst du eine Trim-Komande hinterher und sagst, ok, diese ganzen Blöcke hier, die brauch ich nicht mehr, die kannst du schon mal löschen irgendwann demnächst, damit ich sie irgendwann wieder schnell beschreiben kann. Das ist Trim. Die modernen Firmen machen das aber so, die sagen, du hast jetzt kein Trim-Kommando, du hast irgendwie so einen 100 Kilobyte-Pfeil gelöscht, oder halt so ein paar Blöcke, dann wird da erstmal nichts gemacht. Aber wenn du jetzt nochmal 100 Kilobyte schreiben willst, dann schreibt er dir nicht über die 100, die da gerade frei wurden und muss erst löschen und dann schreiben, weil das ist jetzt langsam, sondern schreibt es auf irgendwelche Blöcke, die schon mal gelöscht wurden, die haben auch Spare, also du siehst die sozusagen gar nicht, sondern das macht alles dieser Controller innen drin, also der röffelt alles nochmal ein bisschen durcheinander. Aber er weiß, dass du sie an diese Stelle geschrieben hättest. Und dadurch weiß er, dass die jetzt frei sind.
Aber bei Trim ist doch wirklich noch, es ist doch nicht nur dieses Löschen, was Zeit dauert, sondern es ist ja auch, dass du komplett den ganzen Blog auch einlesen musst und komplett wieder neu schreiben musst, wenn die Dateile drauf ist. Und bei Trim kann er doch bestimmte Bereiche der Platte einfach als gelöscht markieren sozusagen. Und die kann er dann komplett ignorieren erstmal. Und brauchst du nicht, wenn er jetzt den halben Blog schreibt, ich hab da neben noch ein paar Bites, die schon lange gelöscht sind, aber die dann trotzdem noch mal irgendwo anders hin speichern muss. Und das ist doch der Vorteil bei Trim, dachte ich immer. Und dass wir diese Garbage Collection so...
Na das ist ja eher das Problem, das ist aber fast das gleiche Problem, auch wie bei einem RAID 5 und bei irgendwelchen anderen Sachen, wo du größere Sachen schreibst. Also zum Beispiel bei den Platten, die jetzt 4 Kilobyte Blöcke haben, wenn du halt nur 2 schreiben willst. Und die Platte kann aber nur 4 Kilobyte Blöcke schreiben. Dann musst du die alten 2 Kilobyte erstmal einlesen, mit der neuen 2 Kilobyte zusammenkleben und dann als 4 Kilobyte wieder rausschreiben. Das ist jetzt nicht SSD-spezifisch.
Ja, aber wenn du weißt, dass du die Hälfte davon einlesen musst, dabei hilft dir im Trim weiter.
Warum?
Na weil, wenn ich einmal die Datei dahingeschrieben habe, dann hat die Fastplatte, die SSD, nie wieder eine Chance rauszukriegen, ob das da jetzt Datenmüll ist, was da liegt, oder ob das relevante Daten sind. Und in dem Moment, in dem Trim sagt, du kannst sie weglöschen, dann werden die als gelöscht markiert und die SSD kann besser mit dem Speicher umgehen.
Ja, und bei den modernen Controllern ist es halt so, wenn du einen Block beschreiben willst, der noch nicht gelöscht ist, dann schreiben die ihn einfach erstmal irgendwo anders hin.
Ja, aber genau das kannst du nicht sparen.
Nee, aber das sorgt ja genau dafür, dass man gar kein Trim-Commando mehr braucht.
Wieso nicht? Du brauchst die Daten nicht woanders hinzuschreiben.
Das macht der Kontroll alles von ganz alleine.
Ist ja auch egal bei einer SSD.
Wo es steht, ist ja Wurst.
Naja, aber wenn der Prozess des Verschiebens sozusagen komplett wegfällt...
Das ist kein Verschieben. Das ist einfach nur, dass der nicht mehr eine 1 zu 1 Abbildung von Blöcken hat. Also bei einer normalen Festplatte hast du Blatt 1000 anstelle 1000. Bei so einer SSD schreibt er dir aber einfach woanders hin. Und du musst dich da nicht kümmern. Und dann weiß er aber, dass du 1000 theoretisch überschrieben hättest. Und deswegen weiß er, dass er das jetzt für dich löschen kann.
Aber bei... Also ich hab Trim die ganze Zeit immer so verstanden, dass es darum geht, der SSD mitzuteilen. Du, dieser Platz ist ab sofort Müll. Um den brauchst du dich nie wieder zu kümmern. Genau.
Das ist bei dem, was ich erzähle, auch so. Nur, dass du da das Kommando nicht brauchst.
Aber da macht der Controller...
Woher weiß der Controller, dass sie eine Datei gelöscht habe?
Na, er weiß es... Das sag ich ja. In dem Augenblick, wo du es gelöscht hast, weiß er es nicht. Aber er weiß, wenn du wieder drüber schreibst, dann schiebt er das einfach woanders hin. Aber du hast ja eigentlich über diesen Block drüber geschrieben. Dadurch weiß er, er kann den jetzt löschen, weil eigentlich...
Dadurch, dass das Datalysystem sagt, du schiebst mal genau wieder an der gleichen Stelle drüber. Genau. Aber in dem Moment...
Er legt es einfach woanders hin, weil er kann intern mappen, wie er will. Er weiß aber, dass du es eigentlich überschrieben hast. Dadurch weiß er, dass der jetzt frei ist. Weil wenn jetzt wirklich einer kommt, dann kann ich den jetzt wieder benutzen.
Ja, aber in dem Moment, in dem ich jetzt sage, meine Platte war randvoll zum Beispiel und ich...
FSD-Platten sind nie randvoll, die haben immer so einen extra Bereich.
Ja, also ich hab für mich virtuell randvoll war die Platte und ich fange an Daten zu löschen und überschreib jetzt aber nicht bestehende Daten, sondern ich ändere immer eine Zahl in einer Datei drin und schreib die dann immer wieder neu. Und dann muss er trotzdem immer wieder den gesamten Blog einlesen, löschen und neu schreiben, weil er ja noch nicht mitgekriegt hat, dass ich jetzt Daten überschreibe. Also, dass die anderen schon alle weg sind. Also, das ist sozusagen...
Du kannst ja auch vom File-System nicht ein einzelnes Beit schreiben. Sondern du musst ja immer sowieso die komplette Bloggröße schreiben. So geht's ja schon mal los. Das heißt, da müsste fast schon das File-System selbst dann das einlesen. Das heißt, das Command kommt sowieso. Und dann ist es so, dass die in den modernen oder die älteren, als es die auch, aber die halt keinen Trim mehr brauchen, die haben, sagen wir mal, 5% extra Storage. Und den benutzen, sodass sie die ganzen Daten immer im Kreis schieben können. Und das ist ja auch gut so, weil durch dieses Wealeveling sorgen sie dafür dann auch gleichzeitig noch, damit das alle Blöcke möglichst gleichmäßig immer benutzt werden. Und nicht nur einer tausendmal. Die müssen sowieso die ganze Zeit alles hin und her würfeln.
Das ist mir auch alles klar. Aber ich verstehe eben nicht, wenn die Festplatte nicht weiß, dass Daten nicht gelöscht sind, also ob Daten noch notwendig sind oder nicht, wie sie das ausgleichen soll.
Na die Festplatte weiß es dann, wenn du auf einen Blog schreiben willst.
Also sie weiß es erst, wenn ich probiere diese Daten wieder zu überschreiben.
Nee, sie weiß es nachdem du einen überschrieben hast und der Controller das aber woanders hinschreibt. Dann weiß der Controller, dass der Blog jetzt gerade von dir eigentlich benutzt wurde und gelöscht werden kann.
Also erst in dem Moment, in dem ich probiere sie zu überschreiben, weiß die Festplatte, dass die alten vorher Schrott waren. Aber dafür braucht man doch weder Garbage Collection noch...
Nee, die ist dieser Artikel da von anderen Tech zu Garbage Collection und Trim und so weiter erklärt. Vielleicht...
Liest du denn den mal durch?
Lesen wir den alle nochmal.
Haus auf Garbage zur nächsten Sendung.
Sonst drehen wir uns ja noch tausendmal im Kreis.
Ich glaube, mit Trim ist immer noch eine Stufe besser, als wenn die Firma das halt selber macht. Aber das Beste ist wohl, wenn du Trim hast und die Firma das selber macht.
Best of both worlds, Country und Western.
Deswegen, wie ich vorhin schon meinte, das Wichtige ist gar nicht mehr bei den SSDs der schnelle Controller, sondern was für eine coole Firma du da drauf hast, weil die muss nämlich genau das machen. Und das ist total wichtig und da ist Intel ziemlich weit vorne. Genau, was ich vorhin noch ran schieben wollte, wenn man nämlich mal richtig viel googelt, dann findet man nämlich auch raus, dass dieses OCZ, dieses Vertex, wo es jetzt halt wirklich die schnellste SSD ist, die es gerade so gibt, dass die halt mit ihrer Firma, dass es halt immer nicht alles so super toll läuft und dass die auch schon ganz schön oft mal irgendwie verkacken und so. Also da muss man halt nochmal, da kann ja dann jeder selber googeln, was er sich dann holt. Wir wollen ja keine Werbung machen, ne?
Na wir wollen schon, aber wir können nicht so richtig. Nee, wir wollen keine Werbung. Werbung ist scheiße.
Das ist aber ein langer Artikel, ja.
Das ist extrem lang, ne? Ich überleg schon, ob ich mir den wirklich geben soll.
Auf dem iPad schön zu Hause.
Aber die Geschichte mit dem Trim und wie die den modernen selber machen, der ist eigentlich ganz cool, weil da denkt man sich gleich, warum haben die das nicht schon immer so gemacht?
Weil das ist doch eigentlich voll logisch. Ich hab neulich ein echt gutes Argument gehört, warum man Trim trotzdem noch braucht, aber ich hab's.
Hab ich ja gerade gesagt, dass es auch immer noch gut ist.
Ja, na ist schade zumindest nicht, sagen wir's mal so. Also es ist kein Fehler. Aber es gab noch irgendeinen besonderen Grund, aber ich hab ihn total verdrängt und bin definitiv zu müde, um heute noch irgendetwas zu erinnern, was ich mir nicht unmittelbar aufgeschrieben habe.
Tim, bei der nächsten Mobile-Max-Sendung erwarten wir, dass du wieder mal fit bist. Du warst jetzt die letzten drei oder vier Mobile-Max-Sendungen müde. Doch.
Ach Quatsch, jetzt war ich voll im Saft.
Gar nicht. Vielleicht müssen wir mal einen Salat essen auch, statt irgendwie so einer fetten Pizza oder sowas. Mit Red Bull Soße oder so.
Das Sushi säht es erstmal aus.
Können wir aber auch mal wieder essen. Ich vermiss schon hier unseren Sushi-Delivery-Boy. Hab ich lange nicht mehr gesehen.
Klingeling.
So und nächstes Thema.
Wo wir jetzt schon so bei Platten sind. Es dreht sich ja fast alles nur darum. Aber es ist ja auch richtig so. Weil SSD ist eigentlich die Technik. Ich hab hier noch ein paar Heise die Meldung aufgeschnappelt, dass da auch unter dem blumigen Begriff NVMHCI ein Standard unterwegs ist, der quasi wie man SSDs über PCI Express anbummelt. Daran wird gearbeitet. Und naja, wenn man heutzutage PCI Express sagt, dann sollte man gleich an Thunderbolt denken, weil Thunderbolt ist ja quasi ePcie, der externe PCI Express. Und sprich, das würde quasi externe SSDs Tür und Tor öffnen mit wirklich maximaler Zugriffsgeschwindigkeit.
Na, ich hoffe, dass von Apple irgendwann das Display kommt, wo ich nur noch meinen Mini-Display-Port reinstecke und mein Ethernet, mein USB und mein alles andere Firewire von mir aus auch, ist alles am Display dran.
Auch die Festplatte.
Von mir aus gleich im Display schon drin, irgendwie so eine Platte. Gleich so ein iMac irgendwie, nur halt, ja.
Nur als Doc.
Nur als Doc, das kann durchaus kommen, ja. Ach ja, Entschuldigung, ich bin heute wirklich ein bisschen müde, aber ich hab ein bisschen wenig geschlafen und hab heute schon einen ganz spannenden Podcast aufgenommen. Der hat mich voll mitgenommen.
Du warst auch letztes Mal beim Fremdpodcast, haben wir dich erwischt. Bei den Fanboys.
Die gibt's noch?
Die gibt's gerade mal erst, Mann.
Echt, und die halten noch durch und machen eine Sendung.
Dann musstest du gleich mal so eine Support-Sendung machen, ja. Und dann bist du hier wieder müde. Du hast doch wieder fremdgepodcastet.
Na, Tim wollte halt ein bisschen Industriespionage übertreiben.
Rät's mal nur schön.
Und den anderen Podcast gibt's auch noch?
Ja, natürlich. Es gibt alle diese ganzen Podcasts.
Ich bin ja da nicht so drin.
Ja, natürlich. Es wird fleißig gesendet über Macintosh und andere Themen. Es gibt allerlei Geek. Ich hör das auch nicht alles.
Ich auch nicht.
Wir können schon alles hören. Wenn ich jetzt auch noch alles hören würde, dann würde ich ja nicht zum Produzieren kommen. Aber da ich derzeit so ein bisschen am Produktionslimit unterwegs bin, aber der Fanboys-Petcaster hat gerade mal reingepasst. Da war ich gerade in München und bis der Zug fuhr, bevor der Zug fuhr, hab ich mich nochmal schnell ins Mikrofon geschwungen. Naja, war ja hier so zwischen zwei Sendungen.
Oder sei müde, aber tu so, als wärst du es nicht.
Ja, aber das liegt daran, wenn du einfach keine Marta im Start hast.
Das ist auch schon ganz schummerig.
Ich kann ja auch sagen, woran das liegt.
Aber Marta ist eh nicht mehr in. Lieb Marta ist jetzt angesagt. Mit 250 Milligramm Koffein pro halber Liter. Jedenfalls liegt Marta.
Ich hab noch eine Pepsi Cola im Kühlschrank, die liegt da schon seit Monaten, die wird keiner trinken.
Ich hab bei mir noch eine Wasserflasche im Kühlschrank, die ist noch vom Camp 2007.
Das Problem ist, ich hatte erst letzten Freitag Fett Marta eingekauft, aber hatte übersehen, dass der Durst der anwesenden Hacker überbordend war. Ich hatte nämlich hier ein Geekend am Wochenende in meinem Heim.
Echt, die haben hier gepennt oder was?
Nein, gehackt.
Echt?
Ja, Erlang.
Hast du ja zeigen lassen.
Haben wir gemeinsam programmiert.
Und was?
Erlang. Nicht womit, was? Diverses, aber... Ja, nö, auch. Wir haben einen Brit-Torrent ein bisschen herumgebastelt. Du weißt schon, das ist unser Bit-Torrent-Server. Der auch diese Sendung raushaut, wenn sie denn dann mal fertig ist heute und ich sie dann zusammengeschnippelt habe und online stellen kann. Aber damit ich eine Stunde früher ins Bett gehen kann, mach ich das halt per Bit-Torrent. Und damit das auch zuverlässig funktioniert, gibt's Brit-Torrent. Richtiges Bit-Torrent braucht Brit-Torrent. Sprudel sauber, wer sein Bit liebt.
Ich an mein Bit lass ich nur Wasser und Brit-Torrent.
Ja genau, ich hätt's auch Bit-Love nennen können, das wär vielleicht noch nicht schlecht gewesen.
Bit-Love find ich aber nicht schlecht.
So, haben wir jetzt noch Temi oder?
Mit dem Bit-Tanz.
Der Trecker, dem die Bits vertrauen.
Ja, ich mein, das ist jetzt ein tolles Tool, das wird gerade so ein bisschen das Bit-Torrent und hat jetzt, wir haben dem einen Trecker verpasst. Also wir haben sozusagen einen Trecker in den Bit-Torrent-Server eingebaut, das fehlt ja noch. Das Erlang war lange nicht fertig, aber es ging auch so ein bisschen darum, ein bisschen Fingerfertigkeiten zu machen. Ich muss sagen, irgendwie Erlang, Leute, wenn ihr noch auf der Suche seid nach einer coolen Poemiersprache, die euch wirklich richtig anfixed, Erlang, it is. Es ist einfach mal the choice of a new generation.
Of an old generation.
Ja, ich sag nur Multicore. Deklarative Programmierung, Funktional. Ich würde nicht sagen, dass es fully password compliant ist, aber es hat auf jeden Fall einige Passwords, die die anderen so nicht haben.
Ja, aber er hat auch eine wirklich absurde Syntax, finde ich.
Allerdings, habe ich auch mal gesehen, die Syntax ist der Hammer.
Ja, es ist, wie soll ich sagen, es ist gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Es hält von Skandinaviern, ja. Wahrscheinlich in so einem Wintermonat, wo die Sonne nicht scheint, haben sie sich die Syntax ausgedacht.
Ja, aber ich meine, du musst das positiv sehen mit den Skandinaviern. Also ich meine, wann hackt es gut, wenn es dunkel ist?
Sie haben geschwitzt und die Sonne ging nicht unter Shit.
Und jetzt haben sie auch alle gedacht, sie sind zeitweise arbeitslos und nicht mehr bei Nook.
Das ist so eine Geschmackssache mit der Syntax.
Nee, die ist wirklich schlimm.
Wie sieht die denn aus?
Der Syntax kann ich eine Menge abgewinnen. Wie sieht die aus?
Immer mal ein bisschen anders, je nachdem, wo du dich gerade aufhältst.
Also ich meine, wenn man danach geht, kann sozusagen jede Syntax als schwierig und knifflig gelten.
Ich sag auch, Leute mögen Objective-C nicht, aber ich finde die eigentlich voll okay.
Ja, Objective-C finde ich zum Beispiel auch nicht.
Du wolltest noch ein bisschen über X4 herziehen, ne?
Das ist so...
X4, ja, wenn Tim gleich fertig ist, ja.
Ja, ich zeige hier mal kurz, wie es aussieht.
hab.com.
Ist das alles öffentlich?
Ja, ja, das ist alles öffentlich. Also es ist eigentlich Astro slash Bit-Pretorrent. Wir haben jetzt ja alle, die jetzt daran rumgeschnippelt haben, haben so ihre eigenen Repositories. Das ist halt GitHub. Was sage ich euch das? Ja, du wirst ja Bescheid. So, naja, das ist jetzt sicherlich nicht der schönste Source, den man sich angucken kann, aber der zeigt vielleicht mal so ein bisschen, ob Sache ist. Was gucke ich denn hier mal rein? Ja, ja, gucke mal, so sieht das aus.
Ja, zu wenig Klammern sehe ich sofort.
Na, Klammern sind jetzt noch nicht unbedingt das, worauf ich es anlegen wollte, aber...
Na doch, so, dann kann man die Blöcke nicht voneinander trennen. Nur weil die so ein bisschen mehr eingerückt sind, dann kriegt er die Krise. Vielleicht ja gleich Python nehmen.
Was?
Das hat richtig...
Du bist raus, Dennis.
Klammer auf Klammer zu, das kannst du auch alles in eine Zeitel schreiben. Das ist hier nicht mit Eindrückung und so. Das ist nicht so eine Weichei, nur mal mit irgendwie, wenn es nicht richtig, wenn das Base zu viel ist, dann geht es nicht mehr. Das ist schon so richtig Hardcore, kann man so ordentlich parsen und so. Das macht total Sinn. Also von so einem Blick auf ein bisschen Sauce Code, das sagt einem eigentlich herzlich wenig.
Sieht extrem funktional aus.
Es ist extrem funktional und das, was halt viele Leute abschreckt, ist, dass es sich eben als eine der wenigen Programmiersprachen nicht so dieser C-Unix-Heritage unterwirft. Also sie haben wirklich die Syntax aus ihren Bedürfnissen heraus entwickelt und da ist auch eine Menge History drin. Aber sie ist halt anders. Vor allem versagt man meistens, wenn man jetzt von Erlang noch keine Ahnung hat und man schaut sich Erlang-Code an, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man nichts schnallt, sehr groß, weil man erst mal dieses Prinzip des Pattern-Matchings verstanden haben muss. Und wenn man das aber begriffen hat, ich sag dir, da leuchtet dir die Sonne aus dem Arsch.
Naja, mir hat die nichts aus dem Arsch gerüchtet. Also ich erkenne an, dass das schon seine Daseinsberechtigung hat und auch ein paar coole Features hat definitiv und so weiter und sofort. Es gibt ja auch ein paar coole Projekte damit. Aber für mich, ich weiß nicht, ich mag das nicht. Ich wollte mir immer noch mal dieses Rubi-Syntax auf der Erlang-VM angucken, aber das habe ich auch immer noch nicht geschafft. Na ja, da hatte ich das schon mal erzählt. Da hat jemand halt Rubi quasi, also so, ich weiß nicht, wie heißt denn die? Irgendwie Mayri oder Meri oder irgendwie so, ist auch auf GitHub, hat halt einer Rubi-Syntax auf die Erlang-VM geklebt. Also du kannst das dann halt...
Stirben.
Also es ist nicht ganz so wie Ruby, aber so von der Schreibweise, der Leseart, das ist schon sehr ähnlich und ja, du kannst halt dann trotzdem die ganzen Erlang-Features benutzen. Ja, genauso wie dieses Coffee-Skript, was irgendwie so Ruby-Eske-Syntax-in-Java-Skript hervorruft und was aber extrem viele Leute scheinbar gerade einbauen in ihre Projekte, also Coffee-Skript-Unterstützung. Das fand ich auch sehr spannend. Ich hab nämlich zum Beispiel mich kürzlich damit beschäftigt, wie man so von Webseiten Screenshots macht automatisiert auf dem Server. Und da...
Was hast du schickes gefunden?
Da bin ich auch auf diverse Projekte gestoßen. Genau, und eins davon war Phantom JS, wo man das mit JavaScript macht. Und die haben wir jetzt auch zum Beispiel kürzlich Coffee-Skript eingebaut, wo ich auch dachte, Mensch, dieses Coffee-Skript, das macht ja echt eine Runde. Hier, Raya heißt das. Also R-E-I-A. Raya ist a Ruby-Python-like language for Beam, die R lang V-M.
Raya, R-E-I-A.
Das hat mir zumindest von der Optik schon mal ganz gut gefallen. Ich glaube, wenn du da bei GitHub auf das Wiki klickst, da gibt's dann irgendwie so ein paar, oder die Raya-Homepage, da gab's so Beispiele, genau, hier, rayalang.org, ich paste in den Chat.
Hallo, ich bin Kafka, Hi, I'm Kafka the Cat.
Oh, jetzt hast du in den falschen Channel gepostet. Naja, nur mal so als kleines Spielding für zwischendurch, und dann kannst du...
Der Typ ist Mormona, der das geschrieben hat. Und Fußballfan.
Alle guten Dinge beieinander.
Was ich jetzt nicht so ganz verstanden habe, es war mir jetzt zu schnell. Phantom.js und noch ein JS?
Also viele JS-Projekte, die benutzen CoffeeScript. Du kannst ja mal kurz nach CoffeeScript suchen. Und das ist wiederum eine andere Syntax für JavaScript, die sich auch an Ruby orientiert. Also viele Sachen übernimmt, aber natürlich nicht alle. Aber sich irgendwie auch so um einiges fluffiger liest. Sie haben halt auf der CoffeeScript-Startseite so ein paar Beispiele. So sieht es in CoffeeScript aus und so in JavaScript. Und da ist schon relativ schnell einleuchtend, worum es da so geht.
Verstehe.
Ja, und da war ich aber auch sehr erstaunt, dass das jetzt halt so immer mehr Leute tatsächlich auch einbauen in ihre Projekte. Und dass sich das Leute wünschen. Also ich hab's mir bisher auch noch nicht so gegeben, dieses CoffeeScript.
Und dieses PhantomJS, funktioniert das auch, dass man da mit Webseiten, Screenshots so macht?
Na ja, ich sag dir, da habe ich auch wieder die Büchse der Pandora aufgemacht mit diesem Wunsch. Also es gibt da verschiedenste Wege, der Großteil der Lösungen basiert auf WebKit und Qt, weil Qt halt mit einer Webkit-Library schippt. Und da mit Interfaces und allem so. Es gibt das in Ruby, in Python, in PhantomJS, also in JavaScript und so weiter und so fort. Und alle von diesen Tools funktionieren maximal, würde ich mal sagen, in 98% der Fälle. Es gibt immer ein paar Seiten, die in einem der Pakete nicht gehen und im anderen dann doch. Dann gibt es noch als Nicht-Webkit-Optionen den Firefox, den man auf dem Server, den kann man eine Extension installieren, Command Line Print heißt die, und dann kannst du über die Command Line den Firefox bitten, doch mal Screenshots von bestimmten Webseiten zu machen, was den Vorteil hat, dass du dem Firefox auch noch einen Adblocker installieren kannst und wenn du dann die Screenshots machst, halt auch die Ads rausschmeißen kannst. Und, dass du halt Flash Support hast, also du kannst halt auch Screenshots von Webseiten machen, die Flash haben.
In Chrome geht das auch, in Chrome hat für Extensions eine Funktion, um Screenshots zu machen, Hive ich schon gemacht?
Das Problem dann ist halt, dass du einen X-Server halt noch laufen lassen musst und dann sozusagen auf einem Server, in so einem virtuellen X-Server dein Tool laufen lassen, das ist auch nicht gerade die robusteste Toolchain, kann ich euch sagen.
Na dann kannst du eigentlich direkt einen VNC-Screenshot auch machen.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, ich hab mich jetzt momentan benutze ich WKHTML2-Image, das halt so eine Webkit-QT-Lösung ist. Ist glaube ich in C oder C++ geschrieben und die funktioniert in 99% der Fälle und wenn PhantomJS alle Bugs gefixt hat, die ich gefeilt hab, dann benutze ich PhantomJS.
WKHTML2-Image.
Genau, und es gibt PhantomJS hat halt den Vorteil, dass du nicht nur Images machen kannst, du kannst PDFs machen und dadurch, dass du das in JavaScript schreibst, hast du Zugriff auf die verschiedenen Stages des Screenshots machen, also die Seite laden, das Bild raus renden und so weiter. Du kannst da so ein bisschen mehr mit machen, außer jetzt nur das Kommando absetzen, jetzt mal bitte einen Screenshot zu machen. Aber das ist alles scheinbar auch ein bisschen im Flux und ich weiß ja gar nicht, wie das jetzt mit QT überhaupt an sich weitergeht, ob die überhaupt weiter machen, ob es da diese WebKit-Geschichte weiterhin geben wird. Im Zuge dieser Nokia-Geschichte ist ja jetzt QT auch irgendwie noch so ein... Oder haben die sich schon irgendwie...
Nokia hat es verkauft.
An wen?
An so eine Bude, die auch schon vorher QT Customers irgendwie integriert hat. Vor der letzten Woche war das. Es wurde bekannt gegeben, dass sie das jetzt abstoßen. Ich meine, sie sind jetzt fast den Raubbauern. An ihren Assets betrifft sind sie auch echt konsequent. Also sie schmeißen jetzt irgendwie alles raus, was man vielleicht nochmal benutzen könnte. Damit sie sich voll irgendwie dem Wind ausunterwerfen können. Dann werden sie jetzt 2 Jahre lang vergeblich versuchen, da ein Telefon mit der richtigen Coverfarbe herzustellen. Und dann wird irgend so ein unexciting Produkt rauskommen. Und dann war's das. Also mich würd's noch nicht mal wundern, wenn sie das noch nicht mal durchhalten. Bis dahin.
Die Verträge sind doch nicht unterschrieben, Mann.
Ja, das kommt noch dazu. Also es ist alles so unkonsequent und so dermaßen schlecht für sie. Also was das auch... Der Brain Drain, den Nokia allein in den nächsten 2 Jahren haben will. Ich meine, wer will denn jetzt bitte noch bei Nokia arbeiten? Ja, aber ich meine jetzt wirklich von den Top-Leuten, die jetzt wirklich Competition machen wollen und an der Zukunft da mitmachen wollen. Ich meine, was willst du denn da bewegen, wenn Microsoft die Software liefert? Da kannst du da halt irgendwie deine Hardware rumschrauben. Microsoft sagt dir, was da drin zu sein hat. Alle anderen haben dasselbe, damit sie irgendwie mal eine Chance haben, irgendwann auch mal ihr Software-Update auszuliefern, was sie ja wohl bisher noch nicht geschafft haben. Bisher haben sie ja noch nicht mal geschafft, das Software-Update rauszuhauen, was die Vorbereitung für ein Software-Update ist. Also es ist ja nicht nur so, dass sie kein Software-Update geliefert haben, sondern sie haben versagt darin, ein Update für den aktuellen Status zu machen, der dann das Einspielen eines zukünftigen Updates erlaubt. So ihre eigene Ankündigung. Das war das, was sie versucht haben. Und daraufhin haben sie irgendwie diese ganzen Teile gebrickt, die da derzeit auf dem Markt sind.
Jetzt merken wir auch, mit welchem Thema wir so Tim wieder wachkriegen, wachgerettet kriegen.
Ich sag nur, was passiert ist.
Ich mach mir da auch ein bisschen Sorgen um dieses QT, weil das ist gerade wirklich die absolute Mainstream-Lösung, um so was zu machen, weil alle QT-Webkit benutzen. Gibt's eigentlich, GTK-Webkit gab's doch auch, oder? Aber das benutzt scheinbar keiner. Okay, GTK ist jetzt auch nicht gerade der Weisheit letzter Schluss.
Das benutzt alles keiner. Ich meine, guck dir die paar QT-Applikationen auf dem Mac an, die es gibt. Das ist alles ausgekotzt.
Ja, aber...
Ich sag nur Google Earth.
Das ist QT? Oh, verstehe.
Das erklärt einiges. Das ist einfach schlecht.
Aber ich brauch ja nur QT-Webkit. Der Rest interessiert mich ja gar nicht.
Um was zu machen, da Screenshots zu machen. Na gut, dafür ist es ja auch super. Ich will ja nicht sagen, man muss jetzt QT loswerden oder so. QT ist super, wenn man den Einsatz trifft, aber es ist halt Tatsache, dass Nokia voll drauf gesetzt hat und jetzt lassen sie es halt ziehen. Und von daher ist schon sehr unklar, ob QT überhaupt noch eine Chance hat, in dem Markt irgendwie auch nur ansatzweise Fuß zu fassen.
KDE hat ja wohl gesagt, dass die immer noch auf QT setzen werden.
Ja klar, ich meine KDE ist QT. Es ist nicht so, dass sie das mal gegen irgendwas anderes austauschen könnten. Das ganze KDE ist QT.
Also ich hoffe ja, dass dieses Windows 7 tralala irgendwie ein Erfolg wird.
Ja, warum?
Weil Apple sonst keine Konkurrenz hat und dann haben wir gar keine Features mehr. Dann machen sie den letzten Button auch noch weg.
Konkurrenz durch Microsoft.
Na ja mal ehrlich, wenn wir kein Android hätten, dann hätten wir wahrscheinlich jetzt noch kein Tethering for free.
Das glaube ich nicht. Ja, meine ich. Ich glaube nicht, dass das so viel mit zu tun hat. Ich sage auch nicht, dass es nicht gut ist, Konkurrenz zu haben. Das auf jeden Fall. Das wäre schon sehr wünschenswert. Ich weiß gerade nicht so recht, wer das leisten soll. Ich meine, da habe ich meine größten Hoffnungen auch irgendwie bei WebOS. Aber die haben halt so eine schlechte Startposition gerade, dass überhaupt nicht klar ist, ob die es schaffen, vom Fleck zu kommen. Aber das ist zumindest die einzige OOS-Strategie, die auch mit dem Vertriebs-Background ein bisschen Sinn macht. Was bei Android ja eine totale Katastrophe ist. Also ich glaube von diesen Android-Tabletten wird sich einfach gar nichts verkaufen dieses Jahr. Das ist einfach total...
Wir haben doch sogar diese Samsung Galaxy gekauft.
Wer kennst du einen?
Hast du mal irgendwo eins gesehen?
Ein paar haben sie verkauft.
Ich kenne jemanden, der hat so etwas gekauft.
Ist er zufrieden?
Keine Ahnung, hab nie wieder gesehen.
Der einzige Mensch, der ich im Galaxy Tab bisher gesehen habe, war dieser Vogel, der in der Seabase rumlieft, der halt Werbung fürs Galaxy Tab machte.
In der Seabase laufen solche Leute rum?
Das hat jetzt in der Seabase nichts zu tun. Das war irgendwie so ein Android-Treffen. So ein Android-User-Treffen. Und der zeigte mir halt stolz dieses Gerät. Ich meine, okay.
Du bist beim Android-User-Treffen?
Mit dem Jackel?
Ja, war auch da, ja. Was guckst du mich so an?
Ja, ich bin zwar...
Ich hab zwar mittlerweile den Ruf, mir erarbeitet, der unverbesserlichste Fanboy unter der Sonne zu sein, aber die Wahrheit ist, ich bin aufgeschlossen. Es ist nur so, dass mich einfach bisher einfach wenig begeistert. Also ich will auch beeindruckt werden. Bei diesem WebOS, das ist so der einzige Ort, wo mich zumindest mal die Ästhetik angelacht hat. Dieses Gerät fand ich scheiße, diesen Pri, das ging gar nicht. Mit diesen Nippeltastaturen da, furchtbar. Ich verstehe auch die Leute nicht, die so preisen. Ein Telefon müsste ja unbedingt eine Tastatur haben, mit sich bewegenden Tasten. Warum? Wozu? Warum? Was findet ihr daran so toll? Ich verstehe es nicht. Man hat da nicht umschaltende, kontextsensitive Tastaturen. Das ist total der Nachteil. Aber nein, es muss ja irgendwie was zum Teil sein.
Früher war es ja auch so.
Es gibt auch Leute, die essen Kapern und so. Es gibt auch Leute, die mögen physische Keywords. Das können sie doch gerne machen.
Verstehe ich ja auch. Warum zum Beispiel WebOS nicht auch ein Telefon rausbringt, wo sie die Tastatur mal weglassen, das verstehe ich nicht.
Weil sie keine Software-Tastatur haben, ist meine Vermutung.
Ja, aber das kann ja wohl nicht so das Problem sein.
Na, eine gute Software-Tastatur, das hat...
Ja, aber wenn sie das nicht können, dann können sie dieses Projekt auch gleich beerdigen. Also ich meine, wenn sie nicht in der Lage sind, eine Tastatur zu programmieren, dann brauchen sie im OS-Markt nicht... Dann, dann, dann...
Hat das Tablet denn, machen die den WebOS-Tablet?
Ja, das Tablet hat natürlich eine Tastatur, ne? Na ja, das hat ja keine feste Tastatur. Also da muss ja auch irgendwas eingegeben haben.
Machen sie denn überhaupt ein Tablet, die WebOS-Leihe?
Ja klar! Da kann man sogar drei verschiedene Tastenkursen erstellen.
Wann kommt das? Sollte das kommen?
Noch im März.
Noch im März?
Also würde mich nicht wundern, wenn das nie kommt.
Da, wo das kommt.
Okay, jetzt hier noch Nokia, reicht jetzt. Jetzt gibt's hier, gibt's hier, nächste Woche.
Wir reden doch gar nicht über WebOS.
Ich hab mir von diesem, war bei Ars Technica, war ja ein Review von diesem Xoom, diesen Motorola Honeycomb Tablet. Und das war, also der Review las sich gar nicht so extrem schlecht, aber nach einer Zusammenfassung war wirklich die Aussage und das machte den Eindruck, als ob's von echt jemanden war, der da echt große Hoffnung reingesetzt hat, so dieses Gerät auf keinen Fall kaufen. Weil es wohl in so vielen Bereichen so total anders gelösert hätte.
Heute getauschte Rollen.
Ich hab diesen Review gelesen, ich hatte gedacht, kann man sich ja mal geben, aber wohl die mitgelieferten Programme 8-9 Mal täglich abstürzen.
So, wer fehlt, das kann man auch alles fixen.
Dann muss man's einschicken, damit man dieses 4G-Modell irgendwann mal eingebaut kriegt. Flash ist nicht dabei, ok, das können wir noch.
Das ist das Standard.
Wirklich irgendwann mal.
Aber die Zoom-Webseite ist komplett in Flash.
Und dann eben...
Ein Gerät, das nicht über der Lage ist, seine eigene Produkt-Homepage anzuzeigen. Das ist doch wirklich geil, oder?
Und es besteht den SET3-Test nicht. Und das hat Android 2.3. Android 2.3 schafft das und der in der nächsten Version eingebauten Browser schafft das plötzlich nicht mehr. Die haben nämlich einen anderen Browser drin und der kann kein vernünftiges HTML5. Und so reproduzierbar schafft er irgendwelche CSS-Animationen nicht und so was. Und das Lustige ist, die Seite zeigt, also diese SET-Test-Seite zeigt an, dass sie 100 von 100 Punkten hätte. Also der Browser, der eingebaute. Aber die Farben stimmen nicht, die Schatten stimmen nicht, das schnitt einfach einen Haufen Details auf dem Ding. Und ja, scheint irgendwie nicht ganz so rund zu sein.
Ich hab auch von ein paar Leuten im Twitter gelesen, die da nach diesem Ask Techniker-Review total enttäuscht waren und so gehofft hatten irgendwie, ach, kann's nicht so irgendwie noch okay sein, dass man's...
Ja, ja, hatte ich ja auch ein bisschen gehofft.
Aber irgendwie schien der doch sehr...
Es wird einem auch plötzlich so klar, was so Punkte sind, die sie einmal nicht bedacht haben. Also sie haben zum Beispiel unten diese Leiste, wo sie den Homebutton und so haben, die mitdreht. Also sie haben halt keine physischen Tasten mehr, sondern haben halt alles auf dem Bildschirm und haben da diese Buttons und haben da quasi unten so was wie eine Menüleiste weg. Und dann haben sie oben nochmal eine Actionbar. Das heißt, geht oben nochmal was vom Bildschirm weg. Wo man... Ich bin jetzt so... Nachdem ich mir das durchgelesen habe, sage ich, eigentlich wär's doch ganz schlau gewesen, die in eine Leiste. Dann hat man... So üppig ist der Bildschirm jetzt auch nicht. Dann ist diese Actionbar ausgerechnet oben rechts. Wo man jetzt aber ein Tablet tendenziell eher im unteren Bildschirmbereich gerne bedient und so. Also es ist so... Es sind ein Haufen Punkte, die offensichtlich einfach nicht durchdacht sind. Und dieses... Ehrlich gesagt, dieses Home-Icon. Also es gibt da diesen Back-Button, was gab's noch? Es gibt da verschiedene Buttons. Es gibt so ein Home-Button und man muss wissen, dass das ein Home-Button ist, weil ansonsten denkt man, das ist ein Pfeil nach oben-Button, weil das einfach sieht so aus wie so ein Häuschen, das ist halt dieser...
Ja, verstehe.
Also naja, aber Webbuy ist bestimmt toll.
Wann deliveren die?
Im Juni wohl.
Ja, Sommer war das, ne?
Und bis zum Ende des Jahres wollen sie eine Beta-Version für einen PC haben. Können wir das uns alle runterladen und denken, ich hab schon mit Webbuys umsurfen statt Scheißlein.
Ja, sie wollen es vor allem auf jeden von ihren HP-PCs mit ausliefern, vorinstalliert, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Mir ist unklar, was ein Touch-OS auf einem PC zu suchen hat. Das haben wir ja schon ein paar Mal gediskutiert.
Exakt, das ist auch der Gedanke, den ich auch hatte, als ich das gelesen hab.
Aber sie haben ja diese Touch-PC-Dinger schon, ne?
Sie haben diese Touch-PCs, da würde es Sinn machen, aber nicht alle ihre PCs sind halt so Touch-PCs. Und wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, meinten sie alle PCs, aber weiß ja gar ja, was dann am Ende passiert. Aber auch das macht natürlich insofern Sinn, als dass sie eben den Leuten einfach die Gelegenheit haben wollen, das überhaupt erst mal zu sehen. Dass es einfach da ist, weil du kannst ja damit auch Web-Zeug machen.
Ja, aber du könntest auch einen vernünftigen Simulator ausliefern für alle Rechner und den richtig geil machen. Und dann könnten es auch alle Leute sehen.
Das ist richtig, davon hält sie ja auch nichts ab.
Ja, aber ehrlich gesagt klang für mich das Ganze so, als ob da irgendwie eine interne Präsentation total schiefgegangen wäre und die das irgendwie intern WebOS präsentiert hätten und dann irgendein CEO da saß und gesagt hat, das ist ja total geil, das machen wir jetzt überall. Und jetzt ist die Direktive, dass das überall drauf muss, auf biegen und brechen und dass es bis Ende des Jahres da sein wird.
Ja, also...
Das ist so ein bisschen mein Gefühl.
Also ich hätte auch gerne mal ordentliche Konkurrenz fürs iPad und fürs iPhone, hab ich überhaupt nichts gegen. Aber ich seh sie halt nicht. Und das wird sehr schwer werden für diese Android-Welt gegen das iPad. Also das ist auch wirklich überhaupt nicht zu vergleichen mit dieser Telefonsituation. Bei den Telefonen muss man sich einfach klar machen, dass das ganze Distributionsmodell total anders ist. Telefone werden im Wesentlichen über die Telekom-Provider verkauft und da läuft die Sache. Und die Leute gehen da rein und sagen, guten Tag, ich will ein Telefon, ich hätte gern was Buntes. Ja, mit Browser? Ja bitte. Ist da auch Facebook drin? Ja, na klar. Okay, dann nehme ich das billigere. Dann gehen die nach Hause und dann haben sie ein Android-Telefon in der Tasche, aber wissen es gar nicht. Ja, okay, manche vielleicht schon, aber wir wissen ja, wie es läuft. Und die letzten Statistiken oder Marktzahlen haben ja zum Beispiel auch für Nokia, zwar in Europa gab es einen Einbruch, noch mal so ein ganz eklatanten, ich weiß jetzt die Zahlen nicht mehr genau, aber auf jeden Fall auch diese Feature Phones. Was ja sozusagen noch so zwischen diesen Prolo Standard-Apreis-Telefonen und den Smartphones noch liegt. Die gehen jetzt auch massiv zurück. Und Feature Phones werden gerade quasi durch Android Phones ersetzt. Und naja, das verkauft sich sozusagen über diesen Handel. Aber wenn man sich mal auf der anderen Seite anschaut, das war auch bei Gruber heute noch mal ähnlich dargestellt, alles was kein Telefon ist, da gibt es irgendwie gar nichts anderes als iOS. Also der iPod Touch verkauft sich genauso gut wie das iPhone. Und es gibt genau keinen einzigen Competitor. Das einzige, was noch so nominell auf dem Markt war, war der Zune. Und der ist jetzt, wann war das? Gestern, vorgestern hat Microsoft angekündigt, dass sie den Zune auslaufen lassen. Sie sind nämlich jetzt noch nicht komplett vom Markt, aber sie meinen, es wird keine neue Version geben. Also quasi, sie lassen es sein. Außerdem hat Microsoft auch noch Sidekick, jetzt auch noch komplett gekillt. Das, was sie sich mal seinerzeit gekauft hatten, was sie für dieses Kinn-Telefon verantwortlich war, was auch so dieser Cloud-Storage-Kram war, den sie fast verkackt hätten, als sie da ihre Server am Haupts gehen lassen, wo sie gerade noch in letzter Minute die Daten gerettet haben.
Das war feinlich.
Das läuft jetzt auch noch aus. Also alles stirbt irgendwie weg.
Oder ist noch nicht da.
Oder ist noch nicht da, genau. Dazwischen sitzt irgendwie Apple und verkauft einfach genauso viele Geräte, wie sie in der Lage sind, aus der Presse rauszusetzen.
Wobei es eigentlich doch gar nicht so schwer sein kann. Ich meine, es ist dieses Android 3.0, das einzige, was sie wirklich bräuchten, und da ist das iPad echt schlecht, ein richtig guter Browser. Das ist der, der so richtig, richtig rockt.
Ist das iPad schlecht? Wir sind daran schlecht.
Der Safari auf dem iPad ist jetzt wirklich...
Das ist der beste Browser in der Welt. Ich weiß nicht, was daran schlecht sein soll. Naja, ich meine, gibt es irgendeinen, der so viel HTML5 macht?
Ja, ich sag nicht die Engine, ich sag der Browser. Der Browser ist einfach total bärbon auf dem iPad. Der hat irgendwie eine Bookmarks-Verwaltung, der hat keine vernünftigen, der hat kein vernünftiges Passwort ausfüllen, der hat keine Erweiterungen, die du reinschmeißen kannst, der hat keine vernünftigen Tabs.
Jetzt kommst du aber wieder mit diesen Nerd-Features, was die eigentliche Zielgruppe überhaupt nicht interessiert.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das die eigentliche... Also mich würde es interessieren, ich will einen geilen Browser haben und das ist etwas, wo jemand wie Google eigentlich relativ einfach ein gutes Gerät bauen können. Die würden einen richtig geilen Browser brauchen und alles wäre gut. Oder wer auch immer das macht. Es gibt doch viele Leute, die...
Ja, aber deine Features, die du gerade aufzählst, das ist alles so Ingenieur-Features. Ich will Extensions. Die Leute wollen keine Extensions. Die Leute wollen ein iPad und da muss Facebook drauflaufen und super.
Aber Facebook läuft nicht vernünftig auf dem iPad, weil du kannst nicht mal Fotos hochladen, weil dieses Safari nicht mal Fotos hochladen kann. Ich finde, Sie hätten keine großen Probleme, in Sachen Browser besser zu sein als das iPad.
Ja, aber dann haben Sie Probleme, in allem anderen noch besser zu sein. Das entscheidet sich jetzt nicht nur, weil der Browser Extensions hat oder nicht, sondern das iPad ist deshalb erfolgreich, weil es einfach alle Probleme, alle Fragestellungen, die mit Tablett hochkommen, da eine Antwort drauf haben. Und die anderen haben halt nicht auf alles eine Antwort, sondern die haben einfach Probleme, überhaupt erst mal Geräte zu bauen, die auch nur ansatzweise preislich konkurrenzfähig sind. Geschweige denn, dass sie in irgendeiner Form so eine Infrastruktur vorweisen können, wie das halt jetzt bei iOS gewachsen ist. Also es wird sehr, sehr, sehr schwer, Apple da irgendwas aus der Hand zu nehmen. Glaube ich einfach. Ich wüsste jetzt nicht, wer... Ich wüsste wirklich nicht, wer das reißen soll. Google wird es nicht reißen. WebOS muss überhaupt erst mal ein Gerät auf den Markt werfen. Ich meine, die haben jetzt ihr neues Teil angekündigt, was im Vergleich zum iPad 1 irgendwie so, na ja, okay war. Aber im Vergleich zum iPad 2 kann schon wieder gar nichts.
Von Nokia und Microsoft gibt es da auch noch gar nichts, oder?
Das ist nämlich auch sehr interessant. Nokia hat keine Tablettsstrategie, weil Microsoft keine Tablettsstrategie hat. Also Microsoft hat eine Tablettsstrategie und ihre Strategie heißt Windows 7 für Tablets.
Und wo sind die Geräte?
Es gibt nicht mal das Betriebssystem.
Ja, wird seit Jahren angekündigt.
Haben sie denn halt nicht Steve Baumeis und Slate?
Ach so, von HP kann man da auch was kaufen.
Ja, das ist so, aber niemand will das haben und es ist vollkommen unklar, dass das mit den Laufzeiten niemals mithalten kann. Also die sind nicht in der Lage, ein 10-Stunden-Batterie-taugliches Tablet zu bauen, was ich gut finde. Ja, ohne Lüfter und vor allem ohne Intel CPU. Sie haben jetzt angekündigt, dass sie in zwei Jahren dann auch mal ihr Windows auf ARM portiert haben. Bis dahin ist dieser Markt jenseits von Gut und Böse. ARM ist ja auch gerade dabei, Intel kräftig Ärger zu machen. In allen Bereichen und nicht nur in diesen Embedded-Bereichen, sondern auch da, wo es wirklich richtig wehtut, nämlich im Serverbereich. Da gibt es jetzt Buden, die kündigen so Server an mit 140 ARM-Prozessoren, wo jeder einfach nur so ein paar Watt schluckt und das einfach dann so pro Watt extrem viel Rechenleistung macht. Und in den Zeiten, wo alles eh nur noch Linux und Virtualisierung ist, spielt es dann irgendwie auch gar keine Rolle mehr, dass das kein x86 ist, sondern es ist halt was anderes. Und ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie sich Nokia das so vorstellt, aber das zeigt mir auch, dass die irgendwie die Botschaft noch nicht verstanden haben, weil die sind ja, die setzen voll auf Telefon. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass man erfolgreich, und das hat ja auch Google eingesehen jetzt mit dem Android 3.0, dass wenn man nur auf Telefone setzt, man nicht diesen Mobile Space da ownen kann. Man muss eigentlich auch in den Non-Telefon-Devices irgendwas bieten können. Und da hat Nokia quasi mit Windows Phone 7, deswegen heißt es wahrscheinlich auch Windows Phone 7, eigentlich nix in der Hand. Also ich bin da skeptisch.
Haben wir's geschafft.
Die hab ich gefragt.
Ja, nee, ist ja gut. Ich fand das war jetzt auch alles ganz manierlich.
Xcode 4 hab ich hier noch stehen.
Also ich selbst hab noch nicht fett damit rumgecodeet, nur ein bisschen rumgespielt so. Ist erstmal gewöhnungsbedürftig, aber sind auf jeden Fall ein paar Sachen ganz cool. Also das One Window war ich ja vorher schon Fan von, weil ich dachte, das ist eine gute Sache. Also weil es ja auch mit Line, mit Fullscreen kommt. Aber so unten drunter, weil man dann doch ein bisschen einstellen muss. Also ich hatte mit einem Kumpel da letztens ein bisschen versucht, eine iPhone-App irgendwie bei Apple hochzuladen und da schon zwischen Debug und Release umzustellen, das alles zu suchen und es war irgendwie als alles schwer, schwer wiederzufinden. Oder auch der Interface Builder ist jetzt integriert und die ganzen Menüs, die es vom Interface Builder vorher gab, die sind jetzt in oben im Menü nicht mehr, weil es ja nun mal das Xcode 4 Menü, die habe ich auch alle irgendwie nicht mehr wiedergefunden. Da sind noch eine ganze Menge Sachen, die mir irgendwie fehlen, wo ich nicht weiß, wo sie die jetzt irgendwie versteckt haben. Also das ist alles noch ein bisschen, weiß ich nicht. Also, soll wohl oft abstürzen, habe ich gehört, habe ich noch nicht selber erfahren. Sieht so aus, als wäre da noch ganz schnell mal ein Update demnächst hinterhergeschoben wird. Und das gleichzeitig, wo man jetzt irgendwie 4 Euro dafür bezahlen muss. Also selbst, ich muss.
Das heißt, man muss nur, also man...
Man muss, wenn man nicht 99...
Man muss gar nicht, sondern man hat die Alternative zu 99 Dollar im Jahr.
Aber mit dem kostenlosen Developer-Account kommt man da gar nicht mehr ran.
Nee, das gibt es jetzt nicht mehr.
Und das finde ich schon auch so ein bisschen problematisch, finde ich ja schon. Früher hattest du einen Mac und du konntest dir das Xcode so runterladen. Nee, das stimmt gar nicht. Du brauchst trotzdem eine Apple ID. Aber jetzt brauchst du eine Apple ID mit Kreditkarte. Um das bei Developer Applecom runterladen zu können, damit du mal Mac Ports oder Homebrew oder sowas benutzen kannst, brauchst du ja ein Xcode. Für alles Mögliche brauchst du ja mal so ein Xcode, wenn du mal ein bisschen mehr machen willst.
Aber ein Xcode ist dabei, wenn du dein Mac kaufst. Ist es das noch? Naja, also zumindest bei Snow Leopard ist es dabei. Ob es bei Line noch dabei sein wird, I don't know. Vielleicht, vielleicht nicht.
War es nicht immer nur, dass es auf der gekauften Version dabei war und bei dem OS, was beim Rechner dabei liegt, war kein Xcode dabei?
Doch, ich glaube, das war auch da dabei.
Da sind meine Installer-CDs hier nicht mit dabei, aber ich könnte schwören, dass es immer nur bei der bezahlten OS-Version dabei ist und beim Rechner so mit, war das nicht dabei.
Wenn es mal für 10, 7 überhaupt noch Installations-CDs gibt.
Ich kann mal kurz gucken, hier auf diesen USB-Stick hier.
Ja, also wenn jetzt wirklich jeder nochmal 5 Dollar bezahlen müsste, eine Apple-ID braucht und eine Kreditkarte bei Apple hinterlegen muss, damit er irgendwie mal MacPods oder Homebrew benutzen kann, finde ich schon nervt. Nervig, ja. Also ich meine, für die natürlich total großartig, weil jetzt damit kriegen sie dann noch die letzten Leute mit einem One-Click-Bezahl-Enable-Account in ihren Store oder in ihre Datenbank, aber so richtig schön. Naja, ich meine, wahrscheinlich kannst du dir das X-Code trotzdem noch am BitTorrent runterladen zur Not.
Na ja, aber ich meine, 5 Dollar.
Ja, aber du musst halt deine Kreditkarte, deine scheiß Kreditkarte da eintragen.
Achso, ja, ist ein Problem.
Ich hab gar keine Kreditkarte.
Oder Lastschrift. Ja, toll, noch ein Dritter im Bunde, der deine Bankverbindungen weiß. Ja, ich weiß nicht.
Ich wär ja schon ganz dankbar, wenn sich das überhaupt mal installieren ließe. Also ich hab hier das gekauft und runtergeladen auf diesen iMac und der Installer läuft nicht durch. Nur über den Mac App Store.
Nee, also was kriegst du da? Kriegst du ein DMG oder was kriegst du da?
Einen Installer kriegst du. Du kriegst ein Programm, was ein Installer ist. Weil sie können ja nur Programme ausliefern. Und dann darfst du den Installer starten. Und dann darfst du ihn aber auch noch da rumliegen lassen, weil sonst mussten ja mann nochmal ja. Genau, das heißt, du hast jetzt einen Installer da irgendwie rumliegen.
Abwohl, runtergeladene Sachen kann man sich dann noch mal runterladen.
Ja, schon. Aber ich hab mir jetzt erstmal da liegen lassen.
Ja, sicher, sicher, klar.
War sie noch ein bisschen blöd, wenn er noch abstört?
Wenn der Feed kommt, dann krieg ich einen neuen Installer geliefert? Na, das wär ja ein großer Spaß.
Weiß ja nicht, wie das bei Apple bisher ist. Sie können nur so Incremental Updates gar nicht, oder?
Das ist dann die nächste Frage.
Ja, aber meine Bandbreite ist es auch am Ende.
Na, der Xcode Installer, den er sich im Mac App Store gekauft hat. Aber ist natürlich auch...
Install Xcode heißt der und ist 4,5 Gigabyte groß.
Das ist ja auch... ich will ja auch endlich mal dieses Xcode im System Update einfach drin haben und...
Ist ja angeblich drin.
Ja, aber jetzt im Mac App Store, wenn du jetzt einen Installer kriegst, dann wird's im Mac App Store auch als installte Application gelistet und wird Upgedated.
Wie ist das eigentlich? Wir kriegen jetzt parallel noch ein Xcode 3 drauf. Weil ich hab das Problem, ich hab mir das installiert, dachte so, hab mir ein paar Beta-Versionen schonmal angeguckt von Xcode 4, also die Previous, die es da gab, und die haben sich immer schön brav daneben installiert, dann konnte ich sehen, ah, Xcode 4 ist noch scheiße, mach ich weiter mit Xcode 3. Ich kann mich ja nicht so gut aus mit dem ganzen Scheiß und war dann ganz glücklich. Und jetzt hat er mir einfach mein altes Xcode 3 runtergeschmissen offensichtlich.
Der Xcode 4.
Und das ist jetzt ein Zeug.
Na, wenn du da keine eigene Install Location anwählst, dann machen die immer nach slash developer.
Nee, das haben sie bei den Preview-Resünen nach slash Xcode 4, glaube ich, gemacht.
Ja, aber nicht bei der Final mehr dann, richtig?
Ja, bei der Final eben nicht mehr. Ich dachte, das halten sie jetzt mal bis zum Ende durch. Ich hab sogar hier noch ein Xcode 4. Oh, da fällt mir gerade auf. Da ist wahrscheinlich noch der alte dann drin. Auf jeden Fall muss ich jetzt, weil ich krieg mein Phone-Gap nicht mehr zum Laufen. Dieses Tool, mit dem man iPhone-Apps entwickeln kann. Und ich hab keine Ahnung, was ich da machen muss.
Das Xcode 4 ist schon noch ein bisschen schwierig, weil man eine Menge jetzt wieder umlernen muss. Ich finde, die hätten das nicht so revolutionsmäßig updaten sollen, das Xcode 4, sondern mehr so evolutionsmäßig, so in kleinen Schritten. Ich glaub, das war wieder ein bisschen zu viel auf einmal.
Ich glaub, sie wollten mal einen bold Move machen.
Ja, aber diesmal nicht so richtig gelogen, finde ich.
Robert hier, mein berühmter Arbeitskollege, der macht ja auch ganz viel mit IOS-Coden und so. Und der war auch von Xcode 4 bisher sehr underwhelmed.
Da sind auf jeden Fall coole Sachen dabei.
Aber es soll halt auch nicht performen, dauernd irgendwie Spinning Beachball.
Ja, das kommt auch noch dazu, schnell ist es auch nicht.
Und das ist ja schon komisch.
Ja, ab hier irgendwie rechts unten plus plus und dann so was.
Ach, bei dir auch auf der neuen Kiste mit Spinning Beachball und allem?
Träge irgendwie, das ist immer so hinterher, als wenn er auf irgendein Scheiß wartet oder auf irgendein Timeout oder so. Also irgendwie ist da noch nicht so das Gelbe vom Ei. Und da das jetzt wieder ein riesen Monster-App ist, also der ist jetzt ganz locker rechts an iTunes vorbeigezogen, ist natürlich dann auch mit dem Updaten schwierig, ne? Nee, Tonne würde ich nicht sagen. Das ist schon auch ganz cool. Also ich würde mal sagen, es wäre wahrscheinlich cooler als das Alte, wenn man sich wenigstens damit auskennen würde und die ganzen Tricks irgendwie schon kennen würde, aber dadurch, dass man die nicht kennt, geht das, was wirklich cooler ist an Xcode 4, dadurch ein bisschen verloren. Das ist gerade so plus minus null und dann fragt man sich, was soll das Ganze? Wie so Grönemeier sagen würde, was soll das?
Na hier, die GitHub-Jungs haben sich ja voll gefreut über Xcode 4, weil da jetzt Git mit integriert ist, also nicht nur SVN und hoffen jetzt ja schon auf viele neue Coco-Projekte auf GitHub. Aber wenn der Rest so doof ist, also vielleicht performt das ja dann auch echt erst auf Lion. Boah, ich sehe gerade Xenim hat den Flatterbutton. Hab ich gleich geflattert.
Da kann man eigentlich mal gleich mal drauf verweisen.
8 sind's jetzt. Bis zum Ende der Sendung sind es mindestens doppelt so viel.
Wo ist denn überhaupt Xenim? Ich sehe den nicht.
xenim.de einfach.
Ach, nicht Stream.Xenim?
Ah, der ist ja auch versteckt.
Steht an der Rauffasertapete.
Ja, das könnt ihr mir jetzt noch so oft schreiben. Ich wüsste nicht, auch nicht auch nur eine Sekunde, was ich jetzt hier anders machen sollte. Also ich weiß nicht genau, was da das Problem ist, aber hier wird einfach kontinuierlich hochgeladen. Ich meine, es ist...
Feeder schreibt da, vielleicht ist ja schon...
Das ist halt so eine Infrastruktur. Ich schieb das halt hoch und dann verteilt sie auf mehrere Maschinen und ich hab hier relativ wenig Einsicht darüber, was da gemacht wird. Ja, seit der Flatterbacken erwähnt wurde, geht der Stream wieder heiß, ist das da.
Wahrscheinlich muss man davon oft genug klicken.
Flattert einfach mal Xenim, so.
Ist jetzt schon mal 24 mal?
Ja, super.
Also ich hab auch geflattert jetzt mal, tapfer.
Krautfleckern.
Und noch 24, was soll denn das hier? 24, 24, 24, 24, 24?
Na, man hat schon so einen Refresh-Finger trainiert.
Deine IP-Adresse ist wahrscheinlich schon blockiert da.
Für so diese ganzen Live-Ticker und so, was man nicht alles immer dauernd jeden Tag refresht, wenn man arbeiten sollte.
Na, uns könnte er auch flittern, übrigens. Ob ich auch nichts gegen. Das hat uns schon sehr geholfen hier. Das schafft Bima hier rein. Und ich find das schon mal, jetzt sag doch mal, wie das ist. Sag doch mal was Schönes. Du sitzt halt blöd.
Aber ich hab auch genau das hier auch. Also ich meine.
Ne, du hast nicht die Themen.
Die sehe ich ja eh nicht.
Ja, wir können auch jetzt gemeinsam auf eine Webseite schauen. Wir können ja auch gemeinsam auf den Mobile-Mix-Twitter gucken. Das ist Just Notes.
Aber das ist doch hier dieses, also auf jeden Fall diese, wie heißt die, Simple Notes?
Ja, die sinke Infrastruktur.
Genau, da kann man auch Sharing mit machen.
Ich habe aber nicht verstanden, wie eigentlich zu sein. Da braucht man wahrscheinlich Paid-Accounts für jeden, der teilnimmt und dann irgendwie so was.
Genau, man muss in das Textfeld die E-Mail-Adresse der Person reinschreiben, mit der man gerne... Und dann müsstest du eine Einladung eigentlich kriegen, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht. Ich kann das jetzt mal ausprobieren.
Ja, nee, aber das ist auf jeden Fall hier schon mal ein signifikantes Upgrade mit dem Beamerchen und das ist so für kollaboratives Arbeiten hier sehr nett. Also das hat sich hier bei der kleinen Programmiersession am Wochenende hat sich das schon mal extrem prima angelassen und das ist eigentlich auch so ein bisschen Sinn der ganzen Sache, weil hier wird ja... Wenn hier nicht gepodcastet wird, wird hier gehackt. Uwis gucken, für sowas hab ich keine Zeit. Also wenn ich wirklich mal Zeit hab, Movie zu gucken, dann hab ich auch noch so Flachbildschirmen irgendwie in der Wohnung und da kann man sich dann mal so ein Movie angucken. Ob ihr das irgendwie total anachronistisch findet, dass das Teil keinen Bluetooth-Kopfhörer unterstützt.
Das Ding da oben?
Nee, der Flachbildschirm, so Fernseher und so, die können das irgendwie alle nicht. Komisch, wenn man so computergewohnt ist, dann kommen einem diese spezialisierten Devices irgendwie antiquiert vor. Dann können die noch so viele Pixel haben. Das ist sowieso. Das iMac könnte ich mich einfach mit einem Bluetooth-Kopfhörer davor setzen. So muss ich dann irgendwie laut aufdrehen.
Ich hab ja am Wochenende das erste Mal Airplay benutzt. Fand ich ja gut.
Wieso machst du das im Club schon immer?
Nee, aber so mit dem iPhone, weil ich war beim Geburtstag und der Gastgeber hat sein MacBook beiseite gestellt, weil beim letzten Geburtstag schon jemand ein Bier oder ein Rotwein drauf entleert hat und diesmal hat er keinen Bock und hat dann eine Airport Express irgendwo in der Ecke so hinter dem Regal und hat die ganze Zeit nur mit seinem iPhone Musik gemacht. Da meinte ich so, und geht das auch mit der YouTube App? Und ja, geht auch mit der YouTube App und dann konnte ich dann auch mal spontan mal noch so einen Song dazwischen streamen und so. Das hat funktioniert. War ich ja total begeistert von dieser Technologie mit wenigen Klicks zum Partyspaß, ja.
Und das Geil ist, man kann sogar von seinem Film das Audio zur Dings schicken und ist sogar synchron.
Aber er meinte, das ist nicht synchron, während das das nervt.
Nee, ist das falsch. Hab schon den Film, den wir uns im iTunes Store geliehen haben, diesen, wie heißt das, Identity oder so, den hab ich ja im Club dann auch auf die Airport Express geschickt und das war in Sync.
Okay.
Na gut, das Musikvideo, was ich da auf YouTube angeschmissen hab, das kann auch sein, dass das einfach nicht...
Dass das out of Sync war?
Dass das out of Sync war und ansonsten hatten wir dann nur Musik gehört von daher.
Also ich hab jetzt, ich nutze ja dieses Airplay mit XBMC und hab damit relativ wechselhafte Erfahrungen. Ich wollte mir die Keynote schön damit angucken im iPhone und da den Podcast runterladen und dann per XBMC. Das ging auch bis zu einer bestimmten Stelle super und ab da nicht mehr. Und ich hab das Gefühl, dass dieses Skript ab einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt einfach noch Probleme hat, wenn es zu einer bestimmten Stelle vorspringt. Wofür es aber echt toll geht, ist um Fotos zu gucken. Hast du das iPhone vor dir? Das hab ich meiner Freundin, muss ich ja jetzt mal zeigen, so XBMC und hier und da kannst du das gucken und da kannst du Tagesschau gucken und da alles. Dann hab ich ihr das so ein bisschen anzufixen, hab ich ihr dieses Airplay-Zeug gezeigt. Und hier kannst du guck mal, hier machst du auf deinem iPhone, machst du da Airplay und dann hab ich den ganzen Abend einfach nur Fotos geguckt, weil da hatte sie halt eine riesen Fotosammlung drauf und dann macht das echt Spaß. Wenn du so rumflickst, dann so schön auf dem Fernseher.
Airplay hat echt einen hohen Waff.
Einen hohen Waff? Was heißt ein Waff? W-A-H-V?
W-A-F?
A-I-F-F.
Einen hohen Waff?
Ist bestimmt so ein 80er Wort.
Women Acceptance Factor.
Ah, sag ich doch, 80er Wort.
Robert hat ja dieses Uncanny Valley, was du ja auch mal in der Sendung erwähnt hast, irgendwie quasi aufgesogen und verwendet das hier und da. Und jetzt kommt gleich der nächste Kracher hier. Der Women Acceptance Factor, ja?
Ja, den gibt es.
Und bestritten.
Der ist wichtig, weil, also wenn du dir halt was kaufst, also weißt du, wie das ist? Fernseher ab einer bestimmten Durchmessergröße, da geht einfach dann der Waff dann einfach extrem nach unten. Du kannst nicht sagen, hier Baby, lass uns mal einen 81 Zoll Fernseher zu Hause hinstellen. Und generell ist das ja mit Technologie und Computern meistens schwierig.
Also bei Huckels Freiden würde ich denken, bei 81 Zentimeter Fernseher, da geht die voll ab. Groß auf jeden Fall. Weil man muss krachen und muss bunt sein und muss alles fliegen und sich drehen und dann rockt das nicht.
Aber ich glaube da ist ein Beamer, also weißt du, 81 Zoll, da macht ein Beamer dann irgendwann doch mehr Sinn als so ein Flachbild-Show, glaube ich.
Ja, aber ich glaube 81 Zoll, also Zoll.
Guck mal, da ist mein Sharing-Test gerade reingerannt. Was?
In dein Just-Notes-Sharing-Test.
Anyway, also der Women-Acceptance-Factor für Airplay ist hoch, wird sozusagen jetzt hier gemacht.
Also das hat echt Spaß gemacht. Also es ist, ich sage jetzt nicht, dass das noch für anderes, weil ansonsten Musik kann ich leider nicht mit diesem XBNC, weil das ist ja dieses andere Protokoll, das ist ja noch dieses alte AirTunes. Und insofern, und Filme bin ich, also ja, gibt's ein paar, kann man YouTube-Videos drauf gucken, das macht bestimmt total viel Spaß. Dann kann man...
Das muss ich halt mal testen, ob das wirklich Spaß macht. Also wie gesagt, ich hatte so das Gefühl, dass Video auf dem Phone und Sound dann da nicht so ganz stimmt.
Du brauchst halt beides, du brauchst halt beides auf dem Fernseher. Genau, stimmt. Dann ist es...
Und dafür bräuchte ich dann wiederum eine Apple TV, ne?
Na entweder Apple TV oder eben du holst hier... Na dieses XBMC kann das halt mit diesem AirPlayer heißt das. Das gibt's bei GitHub. Ist einfach zu installieren, funktioniert ganz großartig. Und was gibt's da noch so an Lösungen? Ich glaube, es gibt für das iPad gibt's eine App, mit der du AirPlay Streams entgegennehmen kannst und so was.
Es gibt da so dreieinhalb Lösungen für.
Aber eigentlich gerade, also was das Charmante eigentlich ist, dass der Computer da oder dass du da gar nicht weiter drüber nachdenken musst. Du machst ja eben nur, ok, da hängt ein Fernseher und du klickst halt einfach hier ab auf Fernseher oder hier share mal auf die tolle Musikanlage.
Wobei mit diesem AirPlayer und XBMC, das ist, wenn das einmal läuft, dann hast du genau diese Experience. Also dann ist es einfach da, dann ist da dieser Button auf dem iPhone bzw. auf dem iPad bei dem Programm, die es unterstützt und dann geht das schon alles in eine ähnliche Richtung. Also es ist lange nicht perfekt und mit einem Apple TV ist es bestimmt schicker, aber ein Apple TV kann dafür maßenhaft anderes Zeug leider nicht.
Ja, aber ich wollte es auch nur mal erwähnt haben, dass ich das jetzt zum ersten Mal ausprobiert habe und doch echt mal ganz angetan war, so für Party, Setup und so. Also es war einfach...
Im Club machen wir auch schon die ganze Zeit mit der Musik so dahinsenden.
Ja, aber nicht mit dem Phone und nicht aus der YouTube ab und nicht aus...
Ja, okay, aus der YouTube ab ist was anderes, aber Phone oder Rechner ist jetzt eigentlich auch wurscht.
Das Ding ist ja auch irgendwie...
Habt ihr übrigens gehört, jetzt kam ja das Apple Remote raus, ein neues. Und...
Was kann das neu?
Ich glaube kann man ein bisschen...
Hat jetzt auch dieses Home-Sharing-Support mit drin, oder wie das heißt.
Aha, das heißt?
Apple Remote Home-Sharing? Kannst du jetzt deine geschaerten Sachen mit der Remote abspielen?
Nee, was? Das konntest du ja vorher auch. Ja, ehrlich gesagt, ja stimmt eigentlich. Das ging ja sowieso schon. Aber irgendwie stand da jetzt...
iOS 4.3 hat jetzt Home-Sharing-Support.
Weil halt die automatische Autorisierung... Du lockst dich halt nur noch ins Home-Sharing ein und alles, was am Home-Sharing teilnimmt, taucht halt automatisch auf. Und du musst dir die Geräte einzeln...
Wahrscheinlich auch...
Ja, das ist ja jetzt so ihr Ding. Aber solange sie nicht mal nachrüsten und mehr als einen Home-Sharing-Account auf einem Device erlauben, das verstehe ich einfach nicht. Also ich meine, für so einen Zuspieler mag das ja noch zu Ertragen sein, aber dass es halt auf dem Apple TV nicht geht, das ist wirklich Quatsch, weil im Prinzip müsstest du für jeden Haushaltsteilnehmer ein eigenes Apple TV hinstellen, damit der dann auch das dahin, also ich verstehe da einfach die Logik nicht.
Ja, in der Sparte, da könnten sie auch echt nochmal ordentlich was reißen.
Also das Home Sharing soll dafür sorgen, dass ich die Musik hier auf dem iPhone abspielen kann, die auf meinem Rechner liegt. Das müsste gehen.
Das geht ja auch.
Das geht ja jetzt seit dem 43, seit iOS 43.
Du gerichtest da in den Einstellungen.
Du musst da deinen Home Sharing Account in den Einstellungen einstellen. Das ist in den iPod-Settings. Und dann hast du das auch. Das ist jetzt irgendwie genau das, wo sie gerade nachliefern. Also sie machen langsam, aber sicher so im Rahmen ihres gesetzten Systems, stellen sie die Verbindung zwischen allen Komponenten her. Zeit wird's. Aber ich verstehe trotzdem diese Limitierung nicht. Ich meine, versteht das von euch irgendeiner?
Welche Limitierung?
Guck mal, stell dir mal vor, du hättest eine Familie. Oder sag mal, du hättest eine WG. Vielleicht sogar noch ein besseres Beispiel. Und die WG hat jetzt einen Fernseher. Du hast so ein Gemeinschaftszimmer, hast einen Fernseher, hast einen Apple TV dran.
Dann geht es nicht, weil nur einer die Apple TV besitzt.
Das Apple TV nimmt an einem Homesharing teil. Das heißt, andere Mitbewohner, die jetzt, was weiß ich, eine Apple-WG, alle haben iPhones, alle haben iPads, was weiß ich, alle haben Macs rumstehen. Und auf deinem Mac hast du halt in deinem iTunes hast du natürlich deinen Apple ID zum Einkaufen und so weiter eingetragen.
Das hängt an der Apple ID.
Das hängt alles an dieser Apple ID. Jetzt ist es natürlich so, dass Homesharing und Einkaufen ja eigentlich was anderes ist, möchte man meinen. Weil das eine ja irgendwie nur so, was gehört zu meinem Fuhrpark und teilt sich hier im Homeshare, also was share hat im Homesharing, deswegen heißt es ja irgendwie auch so. Und das andere ist das, womit ich einkaufe. Natürlich hat das irgendwie ein bisschen was miteinander zu tun. Jetzt kommen wir nämlich in diesen ganzen DRM-Scheiß und ich glaube, das ist nämlich der Grund für diesen ganzen Fuhrpark. Wenn ich jetzt auf meinen Apple TV streamen will, dann muss das eben im selben Homesharing-Account sein. Ich kann aber jetzt meinem iTunes nicht Homesharing aufmachen mit meinem anderen Account. Da beschwert er sich. Zumindest war das bei mir immer so. Hier wird wieder behauptet, es sei getrennt.
Der Chat behauptet das einfach so.
Du Homesharings benutzt eine eigene Mac-ID für die Stores. Das geht bei mir nicht.
Ja, aber warum muss man da so viele Mac-IDs? Das ist doch total albern. Die müssen einfach auf dem Apple TV unten drunter, sobald du da eine Homesharing-ID eingegeben hast oder eine Apple-ID, noch ein zweites, ein weiterer Apple-ID hinzufügen, dann hast du eben die Sammlung von beiden Rechnern. Wo ist das Problem?
Das ist halt nicht so.
Ja, also das sollten sie machen.
Sie haben es halt aber nicht getan. Und das heißt, dass es halt nicht geht. So, aber jetzt, jetzt, okay. Also der Chat stellt fest, bei Tim ist immer alles anders. Also das würde mich jetzt mal wirklich interessieren, wie das so bei euch funktioniert. Ich hab das versucht, ich hab auf diesem anderen Mac, der mit einer anderen Apple-ID im Apple Store einkauft, versucht, das Homesharing einzutragen und der meint, es müsste das Gleiche sein. Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, wie die Fehlermeldung war, aber er hat sich irgendwie beschwätzt. Lies sich einfach nicht aktivieren. Wenn das bei euch irgendwie geht, dann blog mal da drüber und dann...
Bei mir geht nicht mal das Homesharing. Wo soll denn da jetzt was auftauchen?
Äh, in den...
Im iPod.
Da ist nichts. Das ist die normale Musik, die auf meinem iPhone ist.
Ja, du kannst dann irgendwie wechseln. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie das ging.
Du bist ja auch nicht zu home... At home.
Aber mein Rechner ist doch hier.
Ist das ein bisschen das Gästennetz oder ist das draußen?
Weiß ich nicht. Kabelnetz.
Ja, dann Telefon.
Nicht Kabelnetz.
Das WLAN an der Wand.
Muss ich gucken, Meterebene nur. Meterebene Public muss ich gehen oder was? Nur Meterebene.
Oder bin ich?
Du hast da jetzt einen Homesharing-Account gerade eingetragen in deinem iPhone. Hab ich dir jetzt gerade nicht beantworten.
Mir ist übrigens auch noch, ich hatte ja letzte Sendung über DVI Display Port Adapter gerantet und dass da die 4 Löcher fehlen bei den Apple Adaptern und deswegen die so gut wie an keine anderen Kabel und Adapter passen. Und da hat mir jemand eine Mail geschrieben oder getwittert und meinte, er hatte genau das gleiche Problem gehabt auf irgendeine Ausstellung und hat dann tatsächlich mit einem Proxxon, wie ich das ja auch in der letzten Sendung schon vermutete oder vorhatte, 4 Löcher einfach da reingebohrt und meinte, das geht wunderbar, das werde ich jetzt auch mal machen und nächste Woche könnt ihr mich dann mal fragen, ob ich nochmal 29€ an den Apple-Store überwiesen habe oder ob es tatsächlich funktioniert hat. Aber ja, ich hab ja zuhause einen total tollen Proxxon mit Bohrstände und allem im Pipa-Pol. Du kannst auch ein Dremel nehmen.
Ey, was ist das für eine Firma?
Das klingt so amerikanisch bestimmt. Dremel?
Dremel ist glaube ich so Black & Decker, oder?
Black & Decker, Black & Decker.
Genau.
Dremel ist ein Standardwort wie Meisel, oder?
Nee, Dremel ist eine Firma. Also zum Beispiel, wenn du ins Bauhaus gehst, um jetzt mal mehr Marken zu nennen, da gibt's...
Ein Bauhaus ist auch eine Marke?
Klar. Da gibt's... Da gibt's...
Dremel heißt der Hersteller?
So eine fette Sektion für Proxxon und eine fette Sektion für Dremel, jawoll. Die machen auch im Prinzip das Gleiche, aber ich glaube Proxxon ist schon cooler. Also ich kaufe immer nur bei Proxxon.
Die bauen schon ordentliches Zeug.
Die bauen cooles Zeug auch.
Ich weiß nicht, mit Dremel jetzt nicht so viele Erfahrungen, aber...
Die grüne Farbe ist voll eklig.
Ich glaube es funktioniert auch, ja, das kann man schon sagen. Also Dremel ist auf jeden Fall ganz schön alt hier schon. 1932, meine Herren. Und Proxxon ist bestimmt eine deutsche Firma, oder?
Auf jeden Fall haben sie alle ungefähr genauso hässliche Websites.
Ja, aber der Proxxon-Katalog ist halt für Nerds schon auch ein interessantes Stück. Oh, mit Frames. Da gibt es halt schon einfach echt viele coole Gadgets, wo man sich denkt, ich brauch's zwar eigentlich nicht, aber wär schon geil dieser Tellerschleifer. Also irgendwann, ja.
Kennt jemand von euch Carsharing-Firmen, die gute iPhone-Unterschützung haben?
Ich kenn welche, die schlechte Unterstützung haben.
Welche denn?
Die BK-Sharing. Hab ich das hier nicht schon mal berichtet?
Ich glaub nicht.
Das war glaub ich bei Holgi. Da gibt's diese, diese, diese... Was war das alles? Oder war das Alfa Romeo? Irgendwas Italienisches, glaub ich, Fiat.
Kleines kurzes...
Und die haben halt so Bluetooth. Man sagt sich so, geil, Bluetooth, aber das sind Autos mit Windows-Taste am Lenkrad.
Autos mit Windows-Taste am Lenkrad?
Was passiert, wenn du da drauf drückst?
Dann fährt das Auto runter.
Weiß ich nicht, ich hab da nicht drauf gedrückt. Ich drück auf sowas nicht drauf. Aber es war halt so... Ich saß halt in diesem Auto und dachte mir so, oh prima, Bluetooth, da kann ich ja ein sicherliches Autoradio anmachen. Und irgendwie, also jetzt an Airplay oder so, hab ich jetzt nicht gedacht. Wobei, das wär ja eigentlich auch mal ein cooles Feature für... Ist ja eigentlich so mit Airplay über Bluetooth oder so. Das wär eigentlich auch mal was, ne?
Ich hab ja mal mit so einem Radio von einem Kumpel mich mit Bluetooth mit meinem Phone verbunden.
Das geht ja eh mit A2GP, ne?
Der hat dieses scheiß Radio meine Kontaktdaten komplett runtergeladen.
Genau. Dass das nämlich dann bei mir nämlich auch passiert. Der wollte dann irgendwie auf mein Adressbuch zugreifen.
Nee, der wollte nicht, der hat einfach. Plötzlich mein Kumpel meinte, ich hab jetzt alle deine Adressen bei mir drin. Ich meinte, Quatsch, kann nicht sein. Und er hat erstmal Bluetooth ausgemacht. Und dann scrollt das auf dem Radio durch meine Adressdaten durch. Ich dachte, ich krieg ne Krise.
Ohne, dass du gefragt würdest?
Ich glaub ja.
Wäre ja noch cooler, wenn er die einfach merchen würde. Dann könnte man so ein Art Social Network.
Also wirklich, also und das war so dermaßen unbenutzbar. Das war echt so eine Täuschung.
Nee, ich meinte mit iPhone-Unterstützung jetzt gar nicht unbedingt, dass ich da Bluetooth im Auto haben möchte, sondern ich, also ich wohne jetzt auch im Prenzlauer Berg und da stellt sich ja dieses Problem, dass man, also eigentlich ist ja das Auto, sollte man hier dringend ja einfach irgendwo gegen die Wand fahren oder sonst was mitmachen, weil wenn man hier abends einen Parkplatz zu finden, ist ja wirklich ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit. Also ich hab hier, also so um 19 Uhr, 18.30, da geht's vielleicht noch so, aber wenn du nach 8 kommst, gerade irgendwie am Sonntag oder Sonntag, dann ist wirklich eine halbe Stunde gefahren, nichts, nicht mal irgendwie was im Halteverbot oder so was. Also wirklich kein freier Platz. Und darum wollte ich jetzt Car Sharing machen, dementsprechend viele Car Sharing, die gibt es hier auch, und da wollte ich halt gerne, dass man übers iPhone Auto buchen kann einfach. Das hätte ich gerne.
Und dass es da irgendwie so eine iPhone App gibt, wo meine Daten eingespeichert sind, sollte das nicht bei DB Car Sharing und so gehen, dachte ich?
Dass sie einen schicken iPhone App haben?
Ich dachte, aber ich mach das nicht, darum weiß ich es nicht, aber ich dachte, es gehört zu haben.
Oder gelesen oder so.
DB Car Sharing scheint mir so, die haben tausende Töchter überall, also Unternehmen offensichtlich, so Car Sharing-Anbieter, kleine Regionale aufgekauft. Und hier in Prenzlberg, also hier im Umkreis von der Ecke, hier gibt es im Umkreis von einem Kilometergrad mal so ein Auto von denen ausgerechnet, Nord Passat, die sind eigentlich schon mal relativ weit draußen. Ich bin jetzt hier bei Cambio gelandet, glaube ich. Die haben hier in direkter Umgebung irgendwie drei Stationen. Das ist schon echt...
Die Deutsche Wikipedia hat einen Artikel über Dremel, aber der Proxxon-Artikel ist gelöscht. Und Schutz vor Neuanlage. Ach, diese Deutsche Wikipedia. Nee, der Proxxon-Dremel ist drin.
Ach echt?
Aber der ist bestimmt jetzt auch gleich gelöscht. Ach man, diese Deutsche Wikipedia, so traurig.
Das ist wirklich traurig.
Dremel, die bauen schon cool... Das hier sieht irgendwie so aus, als ob man echt gut mitarbeiten könnte, oder?
Die haben beide schon coole Gadgets.
Die sponsorieren nämlich beide.
Wahrscheinlich ist das eine Firma, die nur mit unterschiedlichen Marken agiert.
Ich wollte jetzt hier eigentlich noch ein bisschen Werbung machen für so einen tollen iPad-Stand, aber die Webseite von dieser Firma ist so dermaßen schlecht. So schlecht. Jetzt probier ich es hier nochmal mit dieser Item-Number.
Ach du findest es einfach nicht.
Ich finde es einfach nicht. Es ist einfach nicht möglich, dieses Produkt zu finden.
Ich kann ja nochmal ein bisschen über meinen Fernseher schimpfen. Ich habe so einen 3 Jahre alten Samsung Fernseher, oder ich weiß nicht, wenn ich mir den gekauft habe, vor 2 Jahren. Ich habe jetzt das erste Mal zwecks, weil ich jetzt umgezogen bin, wie ihr alle wisst, das erste Mal den Sendersuchlauf laufen lassen. Und das erste Mal so ein Fernseherlebnis mit dem Ding, wie man es eigentlich erwartet. Zum einen finde ich es ganz schlimm, dass es ein HD-Fernseher ist, der keinen HD-Empfänger mitbringt. Du hast nur einen normalen Antennenanschluss. Und du kannst damit kein HD-Programm nativ empfangen, sondern um dieses Gerät so nutzen zu können, wie dieses Gerät gedacht ist, brauchst du ein separates Gerät, was nicht in meinen Schädel rein will. Und das ist wirklich furchtbar, so User Interfaces von Fernsehern. Warum die noch nichts besseres gemacht haben, wobei ich glaube, auch der ist ganz besonders schlecht. Das ist, wenn man einen Sender...
Herr Schiller?
Na, die aktuellen Geräte von denen sind ja okay, aber ich glaube, vor drei Jahren, ich meine, da waren ja alle noch so ein bisschen... Das ist echt früh dran mit dem HD, da war ja auch alles noch nicht richtig Full HD, oder?
Also Full HD ist er. Und wenn man den einmal auf HDMI hat, dann ist es auch halbwegs okay, außer dass wenn der Zuspieler ausgeht, also in dem Fall mein Media Center, dass dann der Fernseher nicht selbstständig mit ausgeht, was ich wirklich... zeigt dann ewig lange Signalkabel überprüfen. Es gibt natürlich auch keine Option, mit der man mal gucken kann, so, nach 5 Minuten kein Signalkabel, geht auch einfach auf, du Dreckskiste. Dann ist der Sound wirklich so unterirdisch schlecht, dass wenn man jetzt ein iPhone neben dem Fernseher legen würde, hätte es vermutlich auf die Entfernung einen besseren Sound als die eingebauten Boxen. Und das ist nicht übertrieben. Die klingen wirklich, als ob da jemand mit einem Schraubenzieher in die Membran gestochen hätte.
Aber was hat der gekostet?
Der hat damals 600 gekostet für 42 Zoll. Also das ist schon sehr großer für relativ kleines Geld. Und was ich jetzt eigentlich erst bemerkt habe, ist so, es gibt da so eine... zwischen den Programmen hin und her zu wechseln, ist das totale Drama. Weil man muss den Modus wählen, ob man jetzt eine einstellige Sendertaste hat oder eine zweistellige Sendertaste. Und wenn man eine einstellige, dann kann man, wenn man zweistellig hat, dann kann man keine eins eingeben, weil dann... Und wenn man so ein Channel-Listen-Menü sich anzeigen lässt, dann sieht man, ah, da hinten auf der 48 ist Pro 7, wo ich gerade hin will, dann kannst du auswählen. Und dann wechselt der aber nach jedem Tastendruck tatsächlich auch den Sender. Du kannst nicht einfach so durch die Sender durchgehen und sagen, okay, den hätte ich jetzt gern. Und das dauert dann ewig.
Tja, wie Oli Stiefja gesagt hat, zum Thema Fernsehen, man müsste mal die Gelegenheit haben, das komplett von unten bis oben neu zu denken.
Hat Stiefja gesagt?
Hat Stiefja gesagt. Das war dieser großartige Redebeitrag, den er oft gesagt hat. War das diese All-Things-D und D8, oder wie das Ding heißt, D5, D7-Konferenz?
Vor ein, zwei Jahren, als du das Apple TV zu einem Hobby erklärt hast oder was?
War da mit Bill Gates auch so was?
Na, ja, diese Veranstaltung, aber nicht in dem Jahr. Nee, das war jetzt im letzten Oktober, kurz nachdem Google TV vorgestellt wurde. Na, nicht kurz danach, aber nachdem Google TV vorgestellt wurde und dann wurde er so befragt, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, was die Frage war, so mit Apple TV und überhaupt und wie das mit dem Fernsehmarkt wäre. Und dann hat er sozusagen mal erläutert, was so seiner Meinung nach das Problem sei, auf diesem Fernsehmarkt, dass da einfach keiner, der da versucht von der Seite reinzukommen, die idealen Voraussetzungen dafür findet, da eben einen Hebel anzusetzen.
Weil du nicht an den Kabelanbietern vorbeikommst.
Weil du einerseits nicht an diesen Kabelanbietern vorbeikommst und dass du eben auch wirklich keine Möglichkeit hast, wirklich da mal so ein definierendes Gerät reinzubauen. Und alle versuchen halt mit ihren Anflanschboxen da irgendwie mitzuspielen. Und dann zählt er sie alle auf. Ja, fragen sie doch mal hier. Wie heißt noch gleich dieser in den USA so populäre? Genau, Tiwo, ja. Und dann zählt er sie alle auf irgendwie so. Ask Tiwo, ask this and that. Ask Google in three months. Und kurz danach kamen ja dann auch die ganzen Hiobsbotschaften für Google, dass sie irgendwie von den Fernsehanstalten da ausgeschlossen werden, etc. Und das ist das Problem. Und er meint halt irgendwie, man muss halt da einen Weg finden, das wirklich komplett neu zu designen. Und das zeigt sich eben, weil diese Fernseher, das was du jetzt gerade beschrieben hast, das klang für mich so wie so Nokia-Userinterface vor fünf Jahren.
Ja, es hat auch ein ganz schreckendes Tier davon.
Genau, genau, dieses selbe Entsetzen ist deiner Stimme. Warum muss sowas Einfaches wie Fernsehprogramm so schwierig sein? Fernsehbedienung mit 102 Tasten. Ja, wofür?
Aber ich muss ja sagen, als ich vor ein paar Sendungen ja davon berichtete, diesen Samsung-LED-Fernseher und Samsung-Blu-ray-Player, das war halt wirklich nur Strom ranstecken, HDMI-Kabel, der Fernseher sagt gleich, oh, ein Blu-ray-Player, Blu-ray eingelegt, hat sofort losgespielt, also war so...
Ja klar, für so ein eingeschränktes Ding, das war auf jeden Fall schon sehr angenehm. Aber wenn du heute mal darüber nachdenkst, wie du eigentlich deine Medien konsumieren wollen würdest, ja, du willst Filme aus dem Netz, lalala, all das, du willst irgendwie alles schnell ranflanschen, ja, es ist kein Airplay drin, dieses ganze Miteinander und so weiter, also der Fernseher als Mittelpunkt deiner...
Aber YouTube ist drin.
Ja, gut, aber das sind halt alles solche...
Aber ich hab mir so ein bisschen in den letzten Tagen so ein bisschen Gedanken auch umgemacht, weil so dieses...
Der Chat könnte übrigens mal... Ah, der Chat hat mir schon geholfen, ja.
Also ich hab vorher wirklich ewig lange gar keinen Fernseher mehr gesehen. Ich hab wirklich bei diesem Fernseher jetzt das erste Mal den Sendersuchlauf bedient und so was. Und jetzt haben wir uns gerade wieder ein paar Sender eingestellt. Wegen jetzt auch Japan und so. Da guckt man ja doch schon mal hin und wieder mal live Fernsehen, weil bis man die entsprechende Nachrichtensendung bei BitTorrent gefunden hat, da ist ja schon der nächste Reaktor abgebrannt.
Ja, da macht der Fernseher auch schon so Sport und... Sport, Mobile, Manx und Apokalypse.
Aber da ist auch so... Was noch ein eigentlich ganz cooles Element ist, ist so dieses Zappen. So dieses Rumschalten, kurz zu gucken, ist es was für mich. Und wenn es nichts für mich ist, dann einfach weiterzuschalten. Und das müsste so ein Ding wie das Apple TV umsetzen. Ich hab mir das so... Es ist so einfach, ohne Verzögerung zwischen verschiedenen Streams zu wechseln, die dann am besten auch noch kostenlos, zumindest angespielt werden. Und wenn du länger als 5 Minuten guckst, dann so, jetzt fängt die Uhr an zu zählen, jetzt kostet sich auch eben 1 Euro für die Folge. Das wäre cool. Dieses Auswahlmenü, und ich muss am besten noch über die Tastatur eingeben, was ich jetzt gerade sehen will und so, das ist eigentlich nur furchtbar. Ich will das nicht haben. Und dieses Seppen ist eigentlich, glaube ich, ein Element, was viele Leute doch sehr beim Fernsehen hält.
Also ich habe aufgehört, Fernsehen zu gucken, als ich nicht mehr gemerkt habe, dass ich beim Seppen schon einmal rum bin.
Ja klar, die Inhalte müssen besser werden, aber so dieses schnell, also Seppen bietet einem, glaube ich, die Gelegenheit, relativ schnell einen Überblick über relativ viele Sendungen zu gewinnen. Und das ist schon ein Feature, was so diese ganzen anderen Systeme sich ruhig mal abgucken könnten, wo sie bisher jedenfalls keine bessere Idee haben, wie ich finde. Also Apple TV und Hulu und wie sie nicht alle heißen. Ja, aber du kriegst halt nicht so dieses Erlebnis hin. Du kriegst nicht so dieses, hier wir schmeißen dich irgendwo rein, sag, ob es dir gefällt und wenn es dir nicht gefällt, dann sag das nächste. Also eigentlich ist ja Fernsehen sozusagen, die nächste Sendetaste ist ja so der I-don't-like-Button, wie auf Facebook der Like-Button. So sagen, ich will das nicht und wenn dir was gefällt, dann bleibst du einfach dabei. Ja, aber das könnten wir auch für Serien machen. Die machen einfach einen Zusammenschnitt von allem, was man so gerne guckt. Und wenn man dann soweit ist, dann guckt man es halt. Aber einfach sozusagen die Inhalte, die man hat, anders präsentieren.
Also ich finde, so ein Fernseher ist ja irgendwie mehr so live. Und so ein Apple TV ist mehr so, da gucke ich das, was ich gerade will. Und nicht das, was die wollen.
Also ich finde ja, dieses neue Apple TV ist ja echt ein interessanter Ansatz. Euch ist aufgefallen, dass mit dem letzten Update jetzt auch noch diese Baseball-Geschichte da drauf gekommen ist, was uns natürlich hier in Europa nicht weiter tangiert, es sei denn man ist US-Expert. Aber das glaube ich in den USA ist, das ist ein Big Deal.
Also ich glaube, wenn ich mit dem ersten Apple TV nicht so ein gebranntes Kind wäre, dann wäre ich mir jetzt den zweiten, hätte ich mir schon lange geholt. Irgendwie bin ich jetzt noch ein bisschen pockig.
Der zweite ist ganz anders.
Ja, ich weiß, dass der ganz anders ist, aber ich bin auch so ein bisschen pockig.
Achso, du musst ja deinen alten Apple TV mitnehmen.
Ja, siehste, weil den niemand haben will, weil nicht mal Tim den mehr haben will. Ich will ihn eigentlich auch nicht wieder haben. Wie meinen alten Apple TV. Man kann nichts mitmachen.
Ich behalte ihn auch gerne erst mal hier, aber ich glaube, der wird dann auch schnell durch einen neuen hier noch ersetzt werden. Das Ding ist verbraucht irgendwie, macht viel Wärme und wenig Sinn. Was wollte ich jetzt sagen? Ja genau, also diese MLB TV-Geschichte, die ist jetzt Teil des iOS-Software-Pakets, sage ich jetzt mal. Nicht Teil des Betriebssystems, aber sie machen da halt diesen Rollout und neben ihren eigenen Store haben sie halt diese Netflix-Geschichte.
Netflix haben sie mit drin?
So wusste ich gar nicht.
Ja, von Anfang an schon. Das heißt, Apple TV ist eigentlich auch die billigste Methode, an Netflix ranzukommen. In den USA ist ja hier auch kein Thema für uns. Aber da spielt es schon eine Rolle. Und jetzt kommt halt diese Basketball-Baseball, dieses Ding mit dem Schläger halt, was sie in den USA, in Kuba gerne spielen, in Japan auch, in Japan nochmal zu erwähnen. Und da ist das, wenn ich das richtig sehe, zumindest für Baseball-Fans schon eine tolle Sache. Es ist sozusagen so ein interaktiv bedienbares Fernsehen für eine ganz spezielle Zielgruppe, nämlich Baseball-Fans.
Ich glaube, bei Baseball ist auch so Statistiken, die sich noch während der Sendung einblenden und so.
Das ist ein ganz großes Ding.
Aber wie bei allen Sportsachen ist es vor allem dieses Live-Ding. Live, aber wenn ich es richtig sehe, live und eben auch aufzeichnend. Das heißt, du hast quasi über diese iPhone-Applikation, hast du ja bisher schon, ich glaube auf dem iPad auch, Zugriff auf dieses ganze Archiv. Du machst dir da halt einen Account und dann zahlst du da irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, irgendeinen niedrigen Betrag pro Monat und hast einfach durch dein iDevice da direkten Zugriff. Und jetzt eben auch auf deinem Apple-TV. Jetzt auch gleich auf dem Big Screen, ohne dass jetzt noch den Umweg über Airplay gehen muss, was glaube ich auch unterstützt wird von dieser MLB-Applikation auf dem iPhone. Wenn man das jetzt mal weiterdenkt, was das bedeuten kann, kann sein, erstens dieses Up-Modell funktioniert auch für Fernsehen teilweise ganz gut, zumindest für solche Nischen. Insbesondere da, wo so viel Mehrwert ist, dass die Leute sogar bereits ein Geld dafür bezahlen, was bei Fernsehen immer besonders interessant ist. Weil es ja sonst sich auch immer nur über Werbung und so weiter und krude Geschäftsmodelle refinanziert. Und so könnte das in diesem ganzen Sportmarkt sich zum Beispiel durchsetzen. Würde mich auch nicht wundern, wenn das hier mit Bundesliga auch bald so losgeht. Und wenn du so einen Apple TV in Deutschland mit Bundesliga verkaufst, wo so Bundesliga nochmal so 5 Euro im Monat kostet?
Naja, die Sache ist ja, ich glaube in Deutschland sind die einfach alle zu trahnig dafür. Ich verstehe das ja auch nicht. Ich bin ja, ich gucke ja hin und wieder mal Fußball, ne? Also wirklich selten, ich jetzt so jeden Samstag Sport schauen. Aber wenn mal ein cooles Spiel irgendwie spannend, keine Ahnung, klicke ich mal so. Oder will ich klicken, geht aber nicht. So, und dann kommt mir von mir halt hier dieses geile digital Fußball-Bundesliga-Pack. Aber dann kann er halt, also der ist halt totaler Bayern-Fan so. Und der kann aber gar nicht alle Bayern-Spiele gucken, weil das Paket, was er hat, ist so ein, da gibt es das Topspiel separat. Also das kannst du einzeln gucken. Aber wenn es halt nicht das Topspiel ist, dann musst du es in der Konferenz gucken. So und er bezahlt dafür extra Geld. Er hat dieses Bundesliga-Pack und kann irgendwie nicht mal einfach sagen, ich will jetzt nur dieses Spiel sehen. So und dann musst du nochmal ein Paket dazu kaufen und noch eins und noch eins. Du hast diese Setup-Box und es kann noch nicht so schwer sein. Also ich meine, es gibt dieses La Ola TV. Das ist so eine Seite, laola1.tv. Da kannst du dir aus der spanischen Fußballliga alle Spiele im Stream angucken. Einfach auf Klick. Funktioniert. Qualität ausreichen. Warum gibt's das? Ich will's kaufen. Ich würde dafür bezahlen. Ein Klick hier für zwei Euro oder was auch immer. Dieses Spiel gucken und es geht einfach nicht.
Ich glaube, die sind da total pissig wegen den ganzen Rechten. Sky hatte doch ewig lange oder Premiere oder wie sie jetzt auch immer gerade aktuell heißen.
Die haben halt Angst, dass einer wie Hucke kommt und nur ein Spiel guckt und sie nur zwei Euro verdienen und sie kein Gesamtpaket verkaufen konnten.
Aber deswegen haben sie lieber gar nichts, weil der Hucke kauft dieses scheiß Gesamtpaket nicht.
Keine Ahnung, warum sie das so machen, aber ich weiß, dass Sky so massenhaft bezahlt hat und die Telekom jetzt das Internet-Exklusiv-Vertriebsrecht oder IP oder wie auch immer das dann heißt, jetzt verkloppen sie ihr IP und dann wird es Sky-sauber und ich glaube, diese ganze Balance zu halten, ist da ein echtes Problem. Und wahrscheinlich ist das einfach da...
Weil es die Cash Cow ist. Alle wollen sie irgendwie so melken wie sonst was und keiner hat den Mut, einfach mal ein einfaches Modell zu bringen. Also wenn Apple hier Bundesliga anbieten würde, dann wär's so ein dead simple No-Brain-App.
Wahrscheinlich haben die einfach andere Ansprechpartner bei dieser MLB da oder was auch immer das ist. Also es scheint ja auch deren eigenes App zu sein. Zumindest auf dem iPad oder auf dem iPhone.
Zum Beispiel bei der NBA ist es auch so, die verticken nämlich Web-Streaming. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie auch Apps haben, aber sie verticken da irgendwie echt coole Web-Streaming-Angebote, wo du in HD irgendwie die Spiele live angucken kannst, du kannst Reviews irgendwie mit Hin und Her springen und allem pipapo. Du kannst dann alle Spiele auch nachträglich angucken, mit wann ist ein Dank und wann ist ein 3-Punkte-Wurf in der Timeline, wo du direkt hinskippen kannst, mit Kommentare zum Ein- und Ausschalten und dem ganzen Viertelfanz. Das hat mir auch der Robert mal wieder gezeigt.
Und jeder Ami-Boxkampf ist so, wo die schon digital verkaufen. Die wissen dann schon immer kurz, bevor der Boxkampf losgeht, wie viele Lizenzen sie da verkauft haben und wie die Börse der Boxer aussieht.
Und da ist halt in Deutschland, und ich weiß nicht, wie das in anderen Ländern aussieht, aber in Deutschland ist das auch echt ganz besonders traurig. Also eigentlich alles. Also weder das Basketball noch Eishockey. Also nicht, dass mich das interessieren würde, aber egal. Fußball ist schon immer erst gar nicht. Die Champions League, warum gibt es da keine Ups zum Klicken? Ich hab ja hier mal gesehen, Real Madrid hat eine eigene Ab und hatte mir schon erhofft, dass die da wenigstens mal so ein paar Spieler zeigen, aber es ist auch alles ganz traurig. Apple, Marta, hier! Achso, meine Batterie ist glaube ich alle, aber... Hallo? Hallo?
Mein ist auch leer.
Steve, mach doch mal was! Ist nicht leer, die ist aus.
Kauf die einfach alle!
4?
Ich bin 4?
Vorhin war das Ding aber schon an. Geht die aus nach einer Weile? Sleep Mode? Hibernation?
Ich hab da keine gute Antwort drauf.
Ich hab noch eine total bekloppte App, über die wir ein bisschen reden können.
Oh, hier in der Sektion iPhone-Spiele. Ich hab ja hier voll am Spiele zocken.
Tiny Wings oder was?
Tiny Wings sowieso. Highscore 139.000 momentan.
Was muss ich jetzt schon wieder kaufen?
Tiny Wings. Ist geil. Das nächste ist wahrscheinlich nunmal Touch.
Dieses Just Notes. Bei Doodle Jump muss der fast auch gar nicht Touch.
Also wenn der Entwickler von Just Notes zuhört, das geht einfach nicht, dass das Ding beim Sinken jedes Mal wieder nach oben scrollt. Wie soll man so eine Notiz im Blick behalten, wenn die ganze Zeit nach oben scrollt?
Du musst das Neueste nach oben schreiben.
Also wahrscheinlich bist du ja letztes Jahr Tiny Wings jetzt noch nicht kennt.
Ich muss ehrlich zugeben, dass ich davon auch nicht nur im Ansatz irgendwas gehört hab.
Also ich verstehe auch nicht, warum da alle so begeistert sind.
Ich weiß nicht, das ist einfach so schön gemacht. Das ist so schön illustriert. Ein kleines, simples Spiel. Was ist für deine Kids genau das Richtige?
Du bist ein Vogel, der zu kleine Flügel hat und musst irgendwie auf Bergen Anlauf nehmen. Dann musst du dich schwer machen oder leicht machen.
Das macht super coole Geräusche und ist wunderschön illustriert. Also wirklich ein tolles Spiel. Kostet auch 99 Cent oder noch weniger. Der Typ ist schon reich. Reich? Ich hab letztens mal geguckt in den Top-App-Charts bei Apple. Das war in 4 von 10 Kategorien auf Platz 1. Und der hat garantiert auch schon seine Kohle oder sein Lebensabend finanziert damit.
Ach, der fliegt die ganze Zeit durch die Gegend, oder was?
Ja, der macht coole Geräusche. Und du musst... Und es gibt halt coole Achievements. Du musst auch einmal einfach mit dem iPhone auf den Kopf spielen. Also alles verkehrt rum, um ein Achievement zu entlocken und mehr Punkte zu kriegen und so. Steht doch da. Aber das Problem ist, es hat keine Game Center Integration. Und da fragt man sich doch echt heutzutage, Jungs, was habt ihr denn da falsch gemacht? Ich denke jetzt nämlich 139.000, in meinem Freundeskreis ist das voll gut, aber ich sehe hier schon im Chat durch scrollen, lächerlich, lächerlich. Aber ich spiele auch erst seit zwei Tagen. Nein, Quatschzeit.
Ach und prompt gibt es hier eine Flinkster App. Flinkster ist von der Bahn.
Und das andere Spiel, das ich entdeckt habe, das meine Freundin auch entdeckt hat, Colorbind, aber das kennen wahrscheinlich auch schon alle. Da bin ich auch voll hinterher.
Colorbind?
Ja, da muss man so Papierstreifen ziehen. Und das sieht extrem ästhetisch und schön aus. Und ist so eine Art Knobelspiel und macht aber doch auch sehr großen Spaß. Und ich saß letztens, also musste ich hier so mit Papierstreifen diese Punkte verbinden. Und letztens saß ich ja so im Club, und da saß der Seite neben mir. Und irgendwie wollte er mal sehen, was auf diesen iPhone-Gerätschaften für Spiele alles so gibt. Und dann habe ich ihm mal alles so ein bisschen gezeigt, was ich auf dem iPhone drauf hatte. Da war auch... Colorbind? Wie schreibt sich das? Colorbind, ja, genauso wie man es spricht. Da war er auch ganz angetan. Und ich muss auch sagen, eigentlich so als Spieleplattform sind diese Geräte echt eine total feine Sache. Und da sind die anderen Plattformen auch extrem hinterher. Auf Android gibt es natürlich Angry Birds. Und Tetris. Aber diese Fülle an echt coolen kleinen Spielideen, die auch echt Spaß machen und die man auch mehrere Tage hintereinander spielen kann. Du hast hier so eine Spielfläche mit bunten Punkten. Und du musst die halt verbinden sozusagen. Und die dürfen sich halt nur an bestimmten Stellen kreuzen. Und das ist halt so ein kleines Knobelspiel. Und das ergibt dann immer ganz ästhetische Formen und ist so ein kleines Puzzlespiel. Finde ich ganz gut. Kostet glaube ich auch 99 Cent.
Nee, 1,59.
Aber es gibt eine Light Version.
Es gibt eine Light Version. Kaufen Sie jetzt! War das zu laut?
Wo wir jetzt gerade schon im Werben und Verkaufen sind.
Ja, bitte schön. Bringen Sie alles ran an jemanden.
Hab ich ja hier auch noch was. Hab ich ja auch noch was. Und zwar... Was denn? Noch eine App? Dann mach du erstmal deine App.
Die hat mich ja auch geflasht. Da saß ich nicht bei diesem Geburtstag und hab nicht nur Airplay ausprobiert, sondern hab ne App gesehen, die heißt glaube ich Abo-Alarm. Ja und ich dachte auch, was? Aber dann hat er mir das erklärt. Und zwar Abo-Alarm macht Folgendes. Die haben Kündigungsschreiben für so ziemlich alle Unternehmen, die es so in Deutschland gibt und wo man ein Abo oder einen Vertrag haben kann. Dann kannst du klicken, ok ich will O2 und ich will das und das kündigen. Dann kannst du die Felder in der App ausfüllen und dann kannst du mit dem Touchpad eine Unterschrift machen. Und dann klickst du auf Submit und sie faxen es an das entsprechende Unternehmen. Und damit ist es halt rechtsgültig. Weißt du, du unterschreibst es, also das fand ich einfach so eine großartige Idee.
Also du kannst direkt aus dem iPhone heraus, ja, es losfaxen lassen.
Genau, du unterschreibst auf deinem Touchgerät, setzt deine Signatur mit dem Finger drunter und drückst auf den Sinn und sie faxen das. Natürlich kostet was, aber...
Was kostet denn das was? Also die App ist kostenlos, aber das Ausführen ist dann bezahlt.
Wahrscheinlich...
Sie verdienen sozusagen am Kündigen oder wie?
Wahrscheinlich ist es ein In-App Purchase.
Das finde ich aber cool.
Aber es spart dir ja sozusagen sofort Geld, von daher ist es irgendwie okay. Mein Kumpel meinte auch, er hätte gleich vier Verträge gekündigt, wo er schon gar nicht mehr wusste, dass er sie hat oder irgendwie nicht mehr wusste, wie es geht oder so. Und er meinte auch, es geht wohl so, wenn es irgendwas noch nicht gibt, dann kann die Community sozusagen auch neue Kündigungs schreiben und Vorlagen mit einpflegen oder so. Also irgendwie, das hab ich, also ich hab's nicht, ich hab selber damit noch nicht gekündigt, ja, aber es klang erstmal wirklich nach einer verdammt coolen Idee.
Als wolle man gleich anfangen zu kündigen.
Besser ist, ich muss nochmal dazu sagen, man kann die Bahncard per E-Mail kündigen.
Ah, Bahncard ist auch so ein Thema, genau. Oder was von Ratiofarben? Aha, das ist ja interessant. So, darf ich? Ich hab auch noch was Schönes. Das ist einfach, ich hab Hardware. Und zwar das hier.
Oh, das ist aber schick.
Sieht ganz unscheinbar aus.
Das war das letzte Mal schon.
Ja, aber jetzt kann ich auch drauf linken.
Schickes Gelogen.
Doch, das ist wirklich schick, weil es nämlich gut funktioniert. Also das ist ein Ständer fürs iPad. Und zwar mit und ohne Tasche drumrum. Was die Sache schon mal ganz cool macht. Funktioniert im Prinzip auch für andere Sachen, die jetzt kein iPad sind. Also es ist jetzt nicht iPad-spezifisch, aber es ist schon fürs iPad gedacht. Kann man aber im Prinzip für alles, was behauptet, ein Tablett zu sein, benutzen. Funktioniert bestimmt auch im Galaxy Pad. Na ja, es ist einfach so eine ganz einfache Plastekonstruktion, die ich aber insofern sehr genial finde. Erstmal unten sind so sehr weiche Gnubbelgummis, die also gut halten am Tisch. Das heißt, es rutscht nicht weg. Und du kannst es halt waagerecht oder senkrecht draufstellen und du kannst es relativ flach machen oder eben auch sehr aufrecht hinstellen. Und das funktioniert lustigerweise auch im Bett ganz gut. Was man ja gar nicht glauben mag.
Falls man meinen Ständer im Bett braucht.
Ich hab drauf gewartet.
War Zeit aufzuhören. Macht mich fertig. Und was wollte ich jetzt sagen? Jetzt bin ich total aus der Spur. Also ich hab es auch als extrem angenehm empfunden, wenn man so ein Buch lesen will, also so ein E-Book. Oder beziehungsweise als Nachschlagewerk auf dem Tisch haben will. Weil dann ist so ein iPad auf dem Tisch flach hinlegen, ist einfach nicht ergonomisch. Und du willst es dann auch eher hochkant haben. Und dann kommst du wieder genau in diese Hüllen-Problematik. Dass es eigentlich selten Hüllen gibt, die wirklich auch so einen Hochkant-Stand haben. Das ist das Teil von Apple nicht. Es gibt jetzt ein paar andere, die mögen das vielleicht können. Aber wenn man sowas nicht hat, oder wenn man eben auch gar keine Hülle hat, dann funktioniert das Teil echt prima. Also ich finde das wirklich einfach und gelungen. Ich bin begeistert. Ich hab gleich zwei davon.
Das ist ja der Wahnsinn, Bob!
Ich hab auch immer eins unterwegs dabei.
Klicken Sie gleich in der Nummer unter Ihrer Landesparte.
Ja, rufen Sie jetzt an, sind noch 18 Stück verfügbar.
Und wenn Sie jetzt kaufen, kriegen Sie noch ein zweites gratis dazu.
Apropos, du hast vorhin mir das nicht beantworten können. Weißt du es vielleicht jetzt wieder, wie diese ab heißt, mit der man seine Röntgenbilder oder seine CT, wie heißen diese Aufnahmen betrachten kann?
Nee, so ist es nicht. Ich kann ja so lange nochmal hier mein sinnloses App vortragen. Das heißt Frenzy, das ging jetzt auf Heise Newsticker rum.
Was hab ich denn eben gerade gemacht?
Das ist ein Social Network Client, also sieht so ein bisschen Twitter-artig aus, auf Dropbox-Basis. Also man shared einen Ordner auf Dropbox mit anderen Leuten und der macht dann in diesen Dropbox Ordner und legt ein paar JSON-Dateien rein und darüber kann man dann chatten. Wie gesagt, relativ überflüssig, aber fand ich irgendwie von der Idee her sehr cool.
F-R-E-N-Z-Y. Ach so, hast du das mal ausprobiert?
Jaja, ich hab das hier offen.
Und wie funktioniert das?
Also ich hab einen Ordner angelegt, hab den mit anderen Leuten geshared, also hab per Twitter rumgefragt, wer möchte und dann haben die mir ein paar E-Mail-Adressen zugeschickt und dann hab ich den allen in Einladung geschickt und dann hat man da so einen Ordner und in dem liegt ein unsichtbarer Punkt Frenzy-Ordner und da legt er so Profilbilder und die ganzen, ja, alles eben so rein als JSON-Datei und ich hab ehrlich gesagt kein Blassenschimmer, wofür es gut sein soll, aber irgendwie fühlt sich das ganz cool an. Also ich könnte es mir ganz praktisch vorstellen, als so eine Art Projekt-Chat, dass man so eine Chat-Software, die so oft Dropbox oben aufsetzt. Man hat sowieso schon Dropbox-Orden, in denen man mit anderen Leuten spricht und mit denen man Daten austauscht und dann kann man ja so, hey, guck mal, hier sind die neuen Fotos vom Wochenende oder weißt du was, da kann man dann doch so eine Nachricht dazu schreiben.
Das heißt, man muss einen Ordner mit all den Leuten sharen?
Genau. Das ist jetzt kein Twitter-Ersatz. Nee, nee.
Ich versuche es nur zu verstehen. Und dann schreibt man da was rein.
Dann schreibt man da was rein.
Das ist sozusagen so Kommunikation über einen Fileserver.
Du kannst auch eine Datei reinpappen. Drag & Drop geht, glaube ich, nicht, aber du hast einen Tastenkürzer, mit dem du Dateien feiner direkt auswählen kannst und du kannst Links auch direkt auswählen. Und es gibt sicherlich Bereiche, in denen das ist extrem praktisch. Stelle ich mir so vor. Wie gesagt, ich fand nur die Idee falsch. Social Network per Dropbox fand ich ganz cool. Kann man sich ja mal runterladen.
Ja, kann man sich mal angucken. Ich hab meinen Bedarf an Social Networks, das ist irgendwie ganz gut gedeckt gerade. Genau, Osiri X, so heißt es.
Ach Gott, das ist doch nicht uralt.
Das ist eine dieser Sachen, die konsequent Open Source und konsequenz permanent aktualisiert wird.
Wo kann man das denn da... ah, da hast du Downloads.
Ich hab da... hast du schon erwähnt, ne? Genau, da hab ich ja mal meine...
Hattest du mal erwähnt, dass du deinen Arzt gleich noch zum Mac-Kauf animiert hast damit und so?
Das gibt es aber auch für Windows.
Osiris gibt es jetzt für Windows?
Ach so, Database-Window, nein.
Nee, ganz im Gegenteil, das ist so eine dieser... Noch, das ist auch glaub ich mal ausgezeichnet worden auf einer Mac-Developer WWDC als so gutes für Integration von Apple-Technologien, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Weil sie bauen halt immer eigentlich alles relativ schnell ein. Also es ist ja extrem auffällig bei dem Tool. Und das funktioniert halt wirklich gut.
Gibt es auch vor allen Dingen für iPhone, wie ich hier gerade sehe. Also für iOS gibt es das auch.
Ahja, schon lange nicht mehr verfolgt. Ahja, stimmt, Osiris HD vor iPhone, iPad.
Aber kostet auch 29,99.
Ja, na gut, auf dem iPad ist das auch schon so richtig vertikaler Markt.
Oh, ein vertikaler Markt.
Naja, Erster halt.
Können wir das SAP Dinglish zum Schluss noch mal einspielen? Mit Women Acceptance Factor und Uncanny Valley und jetzt noch die, was war das gerade? Vertical Market. Brauchst du nur nach SAP suchen bei YouTube, dann findest du das gleich.
Dieses Osiris, das hieß nämlich früher Osiris, also mit Onyx hinten. Und da war das schon, wusste ich zwar nicht, was ich mit anstellen sollte, aber sah immer aus, als ob es extrem viel können würde.
Die kommen bisher so ein ganz merkwürdiges Format, aber das ist halt in diesem ganzen Medical Environment ist das halt einfach der Standard. Also es ist jetzt eigentlich auch wirklich nur für Leute interessant, die in der Lage sind, falls sie mal einen Unfall haben und geröntgt werden oder durch einen, wie heißen diese ganzen Teile? Oh, ich kann mich gar nicht mehr konzentrieren.
Kernspint-Tomographen.
Ja, Tomographen und dieser ganze Fu. So und wenn man dann halt freundlich fragt und sich die Dateien geben lässt, ich meine, das sind ja immer die Bilder von einem selbst, das sollte schon irgendwie gehen, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man das mit Osiris hübsch gerendert bekommt, ich würde sagen liegt bei 100%.
Das haben sie mal von meinem Hirn gemacht, das war sehr cool. Also ich hab nur leider nur die Bilder gekriegt, die dann so derart so an diesen Leuchtkasten ranmacht, die man so gegen das Licht halten muss.
Wie viel Megabyte waren das?
Das ist ewig her, da war ich 18 oder so, als das gemacht worden ist. Das ist jetzt 40, nein, keine Ahnung, wie lange ist das her? 14 Jahre tatsächlich. Das sah aber sehr geil aus, weil ich konnte meinen eigenen Augeapfel sehen, wie er sich so... Hätte ich gern gehabt so eine schöne digitale Aufnahme davon.
So Leute, ich glaube...
Was ist denn jetzt hier mit dem SAP-Zeug?
Haben wir es jetzt? Ja, das können wir zum Abklang im Abklingen becken. Dann sind wir aber auch dann durch.
Wir sind alle durch.
Wir sind durch, oder?
Lieber ständig übermüdet als ständig überwacht.
Was mit dir, Darth?
Haben wir alle Themen durch?
Ja, dann können wir alle, die ich nur noch fürsagen, oder?
Du musst einfach mal sein, die mit der Timmer nicht einschläft hier. Und ich auch nicht.
Ohne Marte ist es echt nicht einfach.
Nee, ohne Marte ist es nicht einfach.
Das stimmt, ohne Marte ist Podcasten wirklich schwierig. Das war jetzt etwas... Aber bevor ihr SAP zu Wort kommt, kommt erst mal Steve zu Wort. Und wir sagen Tschüss.
Ja, bis zum nächsten Mal.
That's what we have for you today, thank you for coming, and we'll see you soon.
Und dann haben wir eine Reihe von kontextsensitiven Operationen, um jetzt die ganzen Urlaub-Funktionen auszulösen, wie.
Wir haben Field-Up, wir haben Fit for Growth, Post-Merger-Integration, Employee-Survey, wir haben Performance-Feedback, aber weniger Connectivity.
Wie kommen wir ans TCO?
Wir brauchen regionale, globale, lokale Views, Mergers and Acquisitions, Outsourcing und sehr, sehr eng tracken.
Geht's noch besser?
Über HTML getunnelt, über ODBO, Oledibivorolab zu dem BV-Server.
Was um Himmels willen soll das denn eigentlich alles bedeuten?
Dass wir jetzt auch einen Fokus innerhalb der Global PSO auf das Thema Business Consulting setzen.